Today I'm speaking with Andrej Karpathy.
Andrej, why do you say that this will be
the decade of agents and not the year of agents?
First of all, thank you for having me here. I'm
excited to be here. The quote you've just
mentioned, "It's the decade of agents,"
is actually a reaction to a pre-existing quote.
I'm not actually sure who said this but they were
alluding to this being the year of agents with
respect to LLMs and how they were going to evolve.
I was triggered by that because there's some
over-prediction going on in the industry.
In my mind, this is more accurately
described as the decade of agents.
We have some very early agents that
are extremely impressive and that I
use daily—Claude and Codex and so on—but I
still feel there's so much work to be done.
My reaction is we'll be working
with these things for a decade.
They're going to get better,
and it's going to be wonderful.
I was just reacting to the
timelines of the implication.
What do you think will take a decade to
accomplish? What are the bottlenecks?
Actually making it work. When you're talking
about an agent, or what the labs have in mind
and maybe what I have in mind as well, you
should think of it almost like an employee or
an intern that you would hire to work with you.
For example, you work with some employees here.
When would you prefer to have an agent like
Claude or Codex do that work? Currently,
of course they can't. What would it
take for them to be able to do that?
Why don't you do it today?
The reason you don't do it
today is because they just don't work.
They don't have enough intelligence,
they're not multimodal enough, they
can't do computer use and all this stuff.
They don't do a lot of the things you've
alluded to earlier. They don't have
continual learning. You can't just tell
them something and they'll remember it.
They're cognitively lacking
and it's just not working.
It will take about a decade to
work through all of those issues.
Interesting. As a professional podcaster
and a viewer of AI from afar, it's easy
for me to identify what's lacking: continual
learning is lacking, or multimodality is lacking.
But I don't really have a good way
of trying to put a timeline on it.
If somebody asks how long continual learning
will take, I have no prior about whether
this is a project that should take 5
years, 10 years, or 50 years. Why a
decade? Why not one year? Why not 50 years?
This is where you get into a bit of my own
intuition, and doing a bit of an extrapolation
with respect to my own experience in the field.
I've been in AI for almost two decades.
It's going to be 15 years or so, not that long.
You had Richard Sutton here,
who was around for much longer.
I do have about 15 years of experience of people
making predictions, of seeing how they turned out.
Also I was in the industry for
a while, I was in research,
and I've worked in the industry for a while.
I have a general intuition
that I have left from that.
I feel like the problems are tractable, they're
surmountable, but they're still difficult.
If I just average it out, it
just feels like a decade to me.
This is quite interesting. I want
to hear not only the history,
but what people in the room felt was about to
happen at various different breakthrough moments.
What were the ways in which their feelings were
either overly pessimistic or overly optimistic?
Should we just go through each of them one by one?
That's a giant question because you're talking
about 15 years of stuff that happened.
AI is so wonderful because there have been
a number of seismic shifts where the entire
field has suddenly looked a different way.
I've maybe lived through two or three of those.
I still think there will continue to be
some because they come with
almost surprising regularity.
When my career began, when I started to work on
deep learning, when I became interested in deep
learning, this was by chance of being right next
to Geoff Hinton at the University of Toronto.
Geoff Hinton, of course, is
the godfather figure of AI.
He was training all these neural networks.
I thought it was incredible and interesting.
This was not the main thing that
everyone in AI was doing by far.
This was a niche little subject on the side.
That's maybe the first dramatic seismic shift
that came with the AlexNet and so on.
AlexNet reoriented everyone, and everyone
started to train neural networks, but it
was still very per-task, per specific task.
Maybe I have an image classifier or I have a
neural machine translator or something like that.
People became very slowly interested in agents.
People started to think, "Okay, maybe we have a
check mark next to the visual cortex or something
like that, but what about the other parts of the
brain, and how can we get a full agent or a
full entity that can interact in the world?"
The Atari deep reinforcement learning shift
in 2013 or so was part of that early effort
of agents, in my mind, because it was an
attempt to try to get agents that not just
perceive the world, but also take actions and
interact and get rewards from environments.
At the time, this was Atari games.
I feel that was a misstep.
It was a misstep that even the early OpenAI that
I was a part of adopted because at that time,
the zeitgeist was reinforcement learning
environments, games, game playing,
beat games, get lots of different types of
games, and OpenAI was doing a lot of that.
That was another prominent part of AI where maybe
for two or three or four years, everyone was doing
reinforcement learning on games.
That was all a bit of a misstep.
What I was trying to do at OpenAI is
I was always a bit suspicious of games
as being this thing that would lead to AGI.
Because in my mind, you want something like
an accountant or something that's
interacting with the real world.
I just didn't see how games add up to it.
My project at OpenAI, for example, was within the
scope of the Universe project, on an agent that
was using keyboard and mouse to operate web pages.
I really wanted to have something that
interacts with the actual digital world
that can do knowledge work.
It just so turns out that this
was extremely early, way too early, so early
that we shouldn't have been working on that.
Because if you're just stumbling your way around
and keyboard mashing and mouse clicking and trying
to get rewards in these environments, your
reward is too sparse and you just won't learn.
You're going to burn a forest
computing, and you're never
going to get something off the ground.
What you're missing is this power of
representation in the neural network.
For example, today people are training
those computer-using agents, but they're
doing it on top of a large language model.
You have to get the language model first,
you have to get the representations first,
and you have to do that by all the
pre-training and all the LLM stuff.
I feel maybe loosely speaking, people
kept trying to get the full thing too
early a few times, where people really try
to go after agents too early, I would say.
That was Atari and Universe
and even my own experience.
You actually have to do some things
first before you get to those agents.
Now the agents are a lot more competent, but maybe
we're still missing some parts of that stack.
I would say those are the three major
buckets of what people were doing:
training neural nets per-tasks,
trying the first round of agents,
and then maybe the LLMs and seeking the
representation power of the neural networks
before you tack on everything else on top.
Interesting. If I were to steelman the Sutton
perspective, it would be that humans
can just take on everything at once,
or even animals can take on everything at once.
Animals are maybe a better example because they
don't even have the scaffold of language.
They just get thrown out into the world,
and they just have to make sense
of everything without any labels.
The vision for AGI then should just be
something which looks at sensory data,
looks at the computer screen, and it just
figures out what's going on from scratch.
If a human were put in a similar situation and
had to be trained from scratch… This is like a
human growing up or an animal growing up.
Why shouldn't that be the vision for AI,
rather than this thing where we're
doing millions of years of training?
That's a really good question. Sutton was
on your podcast and I saw the podcast and I
had a write-up about that podcast that
gets into a bit of how I see things.
I'm very careful to make analogies to
animals because they came about by a
very different optimization process.
Animals are evolved, and they come
with a huge amount of hardware that's built in.
For example, my example in the post was the zebra.
A zebra gets born, and a few minutes later
it's running around and following its mother.
That's an extremely complicated thing to do.
That's not reinforcement learning. That's
something that's baked in. Evolution obviously
has some way of encoding the weights of our
neural nets in ATCGs, and I have no idea
how that works, but it apparently works.
Brains just came from a very different process,
and I'm very hesitant to take inspiration from it
because we're not actually running that process.
In my post, I said we're not building animals.
We're building ghosts or spirits or
whatever people want to call it, because
we're not doing training by evolution.
We're doing training by imitation of humans
and the data that they've put on the Internet.
You end up with these ethereal spirit entities
because they're fully digital
and they're mimicking humans.
It's a different kind of intelligence.
If you imagine a space of intelligences,
we're starting off at a different point almost.
We're not really building animals. But it's also
possible to make them a bit more animal-like
over time, and I think we should be doing that.
One more point. I do feel Sutton has a very...
His framework is, "We want to build animals."
I think that would be wonderful if we can
get that to work. That would be amazing.
If there were a single algorithm that you
can just run on the Internet and it learns
everything, that would be incredible.
I'm not sure that it exists and that's
certainly not what animals do, because
animals have this outer loop of evolution.
A lot of what looks like learning is
more like maturation of the brain.
I think there's very little
reinforcement learning for animals.
A lot of the reinforcement learning is more
like motor tasks; it's not intelligence tasks.
So I actually kind of think humans
don’t really use RL, roughly speaking.
Can you repeat the last sentence?
A lot of that intelligence is
not motor task…it's what, sorry?
A lot of the reinforcement learning, in my
perspective, would be things that are a lot more
motor-like, simple tasks like throwing a hoop.
But I don't think that humans use reinforcement
learning for a lot of intelligence tasks
like problem-solving and so on.
That doesn't mean we shouldn't
do that for research, but I just feel
like that's what animals do or don't.
I'm going to take a second to digest that
because there are a lot of different ideas.
Here’s one clarifying question I can
ask to understand the perspective.
You suggest that evolution is doing
the kind of thing that pre-training
does in the sense of building something
which can then understand the world.
The difference is that evolution
has to be titrated in the case
of humans through three gigabytes of DNA.
That's very unlike the weights of a model.
Literally, the weights of the model are
a brain, which obviously does not exist
in the sperm and the egg.
So it has to be grown.
Also, the information for every single
synapse in the brain simply cannot exist
in the three gigabytes that exist in the DNA.
Evolution seems closer to finding the algorithm
which then does the lifetime learning.
Now, maybe the lifetime learning is
not analogous to RL, to your point.
Is that compatible with the thing you
were saying, or would you disagree with that?
I think so. I would agree with you that there's
some miraculous compression
going on because obviously,
the weights of the neural net are not stored
in ATCGs. There's some dramatic compression.
There are some learning algorithms encoded that
take over and do some of the learning online.
I definitely agree with you on that.
I would say I'm a lot more practically minded.
I don't come at it from the
perspective of, let's build animals.
I come from it from the perspective
of, let's build useful things.
I have a hard hat on, and I'm just
observing that we're not going to do
evolution, because I don't know how to do that.
But it does turn out we can build these ghosts,
spirit-like entities, by imitating internet
documents. This works. It's a way to bring you
up to something that has a lot of built-in
knowledge and intelligence in some way,
similar to maybe what evolution has done.
That's why I call pre-training
this crappy evolution.
It's the practically possible version
with our technology and what we have available
to us to get to a starting point where we can do
things like reinforcement learning and so on.
Just to steelman the other perspective,
after doing this Sutton interview and thinking
about it a bit, he has an important point here.
Evolution does not give us the knowledge, really.
It gives us the algorithm to find the knowledge,
and that seems different from pre-training.
Perhaps the perspective is that pre-training helps
build the kind of entity which can learn better.
It teaches meta-learning, and therefore
it is similar to finding an algorithm.
But if it's "Evolution gives us knowledge,
pre-training gives us knowledge,"
that analogy seems to break down.
It's subtle and I think you're right to
push back on it, but basically the thing
that pre-training is doing, you're getting
the next-token predictor over the internet,
and you're training that into a neural net.
It's doing two things that are unrelated.
Number one, it's picking up all
this knowledge, as I call it.
Number two, it's actually becoming intelligent.
By observing the algorithmic patterns in the
internet, it boots up all these little circuits
and algorithms inside the neural net to do things
like in-context learning and all this stuff.
You don't need or want the knowledge.
I think that's probably holding back the neural
networks overall because it's getting them to rely
on the knowledge a little too much sometimes.
For example, I feel agents, one thing they're
not very good at, is going off the data
manifold of what exists on the internet.
If they had less knowledge or less
memory, maybe they would be better.
What I think we have to do going forward—and
this would be part of the research paradigms—is
figure out ways to remove some of the knowledge
and to keep what I call this cognitive core.
It's this intelligent entity that is stripped from
knowledge but contains the algorithms and contains
the magic of intelligence and problem-solving
and the strategies of it and all this stuff.
There's so much interesting stuff there. Let's
start with in-context learning. This is an
obvious point, but I think it's worth just
saying it explicitly and meditating on it.
The situation in which these models seem the most
intelligent—in which I talk to them and I'm like,
"Wow, there's really something on the other end
that's responding to me thinking about things—is
if it makes a mistake it's like, "Oh wait, that's
the wrong way to think about it. I'm backing up."
All that is happening in context.
That's where I feel like the real
intelligence is that you can visibly see.
That in-context learning process is
developed by gradient descent on pre-training.
It spontaneously meta-learns in-context learning,
but the in-context learning itself is not
gradient descent, in the same way that our
lifetime intelligence as humans to be able
to do things is conditioned by evolution
but our learning during our lifetime is
happening through some other process.
I don't fully agree with that, but
you should continue your thought.
Well, I'm very curious to understand
how that analogy breaks down.
I'm hesitant to say that in-context
learning is not doing gradient descent.
It's not doing explicit gradient descent.
In-context learning is pattern completion
within a token window.
It just turns out that there's
a huge amount of patterns on the internet.
You're right, the model learns to complete
the pattern, and that's inside the weights.
The weights of the neural network are trying
to discover patterns and complete the pattern.
There's some adaptation that happens inside
the neural network, which is magical
and just falls out from the internet
just because there's a lot of patterns.
I will say that there have been some papers
that I thought were interesting that look at
the mechanisms behind in-context learning.
I do think it's possible that in-context
learning runs a small gradient descent loop
internally in the layers of the neural network.
I recall one paper in particular where they were
doing linear regression using in-context learning.
Your inputs into the neural network are XY pairs,
XY, XY, XY that happen to be on the line.
Then you do X and you expect Y.
The neural network, when you train it
in this way, does linear regression.
Normally when you would run linear regression, you
have a small gradient descent optimizer that looks
at XY, looks at an error, calculates the gradient
of the weights and does the update a few times.
It just turns out that when they looked at the
weights of that in-context learning algorithm,
they found some analogies to
gradient descent mechanics.
In fact, I think the paper was even stronger
because they hardcoded the weights of a neural
network to do gradient descent through
attention and all the internals of the
neural network. That's just my only pushback.
Who knows how in-context learning works,
but I think that it's probably doing a bit of some
funky gradient descent internally. I think that
that's possible. I was only pushing back on your
saying that it's not doing in-context learning.
Who knows what it's doing, but it's probably maybe
doing something similar to it, but we don't know.
So then it's worth thinking okay, if
in-context learning and pre-training
are both implementing something like gradient
descent, why does it feel like with in-context
learning we're getting to this continual
learning, real intelligence-like thing?
Whereas you don't get the analogous feeling just
from pre-training. You could argue that. If it's
the same algorithm, what could be different?
One way you could think about it is,
how much information does the model store
per information it receives from training?
If you look at pre-training, if
you look at Llama 3 for example,
I think it's trained on 15 trillion tokens.
If you look at the 70B model, that would
be the equivalent of 0.07 bits per
token that it sees in pre-training,
in terms of the information in the weights
of the model compared to the tokens it reads.
Whereas if you look at the KV cache
and how it grows per additional token
in in-context learning, it's like 320 kilobytes.
So that's a 35 million-fold difference in how much
information per token is assimilated by the model.
I wonder if that's relevant at all.
I kind of agree. The way I usually put this is
that anything that happens during the training of
the neural network, the knowledge is only a hazy
recollection of what happened in training time.
That's because the compression is dramatic.
You're taking 15 trillion tokens and you're
compressing it to just your final neural
network of a few billion parameters.
Obviously it's a massive
amount of compression going on.
So I refer to it as a hazy
recollection of the internet documents.
Whereas anything that happens in the
context window of the neural network—you're
plugging in all the tokens and building up
all those KV cache representations—is very
directly accessible to the neural net.
So I compare the KV cache and the stuff
that happens at test time to
more like a working memory.
All the stuff that's in the context window is
very directly accessible to the neural net.
There's always these almost surprising
analogies between LLMs and humans.
I find them surprising because we're not
trying to build a human brain directly.
We're just finding that this
works and we're doing it.
But I do think that anything
that's in the weights, it's a
hazy recollection of what you read a year ago.
Anything that you give it as a context at test
time is directly in the working memory.
That's a very powerful analogy to
think through things.
When you, for example,
go to an LLM and you ask it about some book
and what happened in it, like Nick Lane's
book or something like that, the LLM will often
give you some stuff which is roughly correct.
But if you give it the full chapter and ask it
questions, you're going to get much better results
because it's now loaded in the
working memory of the model.
So a very long way of saying
I agree and that's why.
Stepping back, what is the part
about human intelligence that we
have most failed to replicate with these models?
Just a lot of it. So maybe one way to think
about it, I don't know if this is the best way,
but I almost feel like — again, making these
analogies imperfect as they are — we've stumbled
by with the transformer neural network,
which is extremely powerful, very general.
You can train transformers on audio, or
video, or text, or whatever you want,
and it just learns patterns and they're
very powerful, and it works really well.
That to me almost indicates that this
is some piece of cortical tissue.
It's something like that, because the
cortex is famously very plastic as well.
You can rewire parts of brains.
There were the slightly gruesome experiments
with rewiring the visual cortex to the auditory
cortex, and this animal learned fine, et cetera.
So I think that this is cortical tissue.
I think when we're doing reasoning and
planning inside the neural networks, doing
reasoning traces for thinking models,
that's kind of like the prefrontal cortex.
Maybe those are like little checkmarks,
but I still think there are many brain
parts and nuclei that are not explored.
For example, there's a basal ganglia doing a
bit of reinforcement learning when we fine-tune
the models on reinforcement learning. But where's
the hippocampus? Not obvious what that would be.
Some parts are probably not important.
Maybe the cerebellum is not important
to cognition, its thoughts, so
maybe we can skip some of it.
But I still think there's, for example, the
amygdala, all the emotions and instincts.
There's probably a bunch of other nuclei
in the brain that are very ancient that
I don't think we've really replicated.
I don't know that we should be pursuing the
building of an analog of a human brain.
I'm an engineer mostly at heart.
Maybe another way to answer the question is that
you're not going to hire this thing as an intern.
It's missing a lot of it because it comes with
a lot of these cognitive deficits that we all
intuitively feel when we talk to the models.
So it's not fully there yet.
You can look at it as not all the
brain parts are checked off yet.
This is maybe relevant to the question of thinking
about how fast these issues will be solved.
Sometimes people will say
about continual learning,
"Look, you could easily replicate this capability.
Just as in-context learning emerged spontaneously
as a result of pre-training, continual
learning over longer horizons will emerge
spontaneously if the model is incentivized to
recollect information over longer horizons,
or horizons longer than one session."
So if there's some outer loop RL which has
many sessions within that outer loop, then this
continual learning where it fine-tunes itself,
or it writes to an external memory or
something, will just emerge spontaneously.
Do you think things like that are plausible?
I just don't have a prior over
how plausible that is.
How likely is that to happen?
I don't know that I fully resonate with that.
These models, when you boot them up and they have
zero tokens in the window, they're always
restarting from scratch where they were.
So I don't know in that
worldview what it looks like.
Maybe making some analogies to humans—just because
I think it's roughly concrete and interesting to
think through—I feel like when I'm awake, I'm
building up a context window of stuff that's
happening during the day.
But when I go to sleep,
something magical happens where I don't
think that context window stays around.
There's some process of distillation
into the weights of my brain.
This happens during sleep and all this stuff.
We don't have an equivalent
of that in large language models.
That's to me more adjacent to when you talk
about continual learning and so on as absent.
These models don't really have a distillation
phase of taking what happened, analyzing it
obsessively, thinking through it, doing some
synthetic data generation process and distilling
it back into the weights, and maybe having
a specific neural net per person. Maybe it's
a LoRA. It's not a full-weight neural network.
It's just some small sparse subset
of the weights that are changed.
But we do want to create ways of creating
these individuals that have very long context.
It's not only remaining in the context window
because the context windows grow very, very long.
Maybe we have some very elaborate,
sparse attention over it.
But I still think that humans obviously have some
process for distilling some of that knowledge
into the weights. We're missing it. I do also
think that humans have some very elaborate,
sparse attention scheme, which I think
we're starting to see some early hints of.
DeepSeek v3.2 just came out and I saw that they
have sparse attention as an example, and this is
one way to have very, very long context windows.
So I feel like we are redoing a lot of the
cognitive tricks that evolution came up
with through a very different process.
But we're going to converge on a
similar architecture cognitively.
In 10 years, do you think it'll still be something
like a transformer, but with much more modified
attention and more sparse MLPs and so forth?
The way I like to think about it is
translation invariance in time.
So 10 years ago, where were we? 2015.
In 2015, we had convolutional neural networks
primarily, residual networks just came out.
So remarkably similar, I guess, but quite a
bit different still. The transformer was not
around. All these more modern tweaks
on the transformer were not around.
Maybe some of the things that we can bet on, I
think in 10 years by translational equivariance,
is that we're still training giant neural
networks with a forward backward pass and
update through gradient descent,
but maybe it looks a bit different,
and it's just that everything is much bigger.
Recently I went back all the way to 1989 which
was a fun exercise for me, a few years ago,
because I was reproducing Yann LeCun's 1989
convolutional network, which was the first neural
network I'm aware of trained via gradient descent,
like modern neural network trained
gradient descent on digit recognition.
I was just interested in
how I could modernize this.
How much of this is algorithms?
How much of this is data?
How much of this progress is compute and systems?
I was able to very quickly halve the learning
just by time traveling by 33 years.
So if I time travel by algorithms 33 years,
I could adjust what Yann LeCun did
in 1989, and I could halve the error.
But to get further gains, I
had to add a lot more data,
I had to 10x the training set, and then I
had to add more computational optimizations.
I had to train for much longer with dropout
and other regularization techniques.
So all these things have
to improve simultaneously.
We're probably going to have a lot more
data, we're probably going to have a lot
better hardware, probably going to have a lot
better kernels and software, we're probably
going to have better algorithms.
All of those, it's almost like
no one of them is winning too much.
All of them are surprisingly equal.
This has been the trend for a while.
So to answer your question, I expect differences
algorithmically to what's happening today.
But I do also expect that some of the
things that have stuck around for a very
long time will probably still be there.
It's probably still a giant neural network trained
with gradient descent. That would be my guess.
It's surprising that all of those things
together only halved the error, 30 years
of progress…. Maybe half is a lot. Because if
you halve the error, that actually means that…
Half is a lot. But I guess what was shocking to me
is everything needs to improve across the board:
architecture, optimizer, loss function.
It also has improved across the board forever.
So I expect all those
changes to be alive and well.
Yeah. I was about to ask you a very
similar question about nanochat.
Since you just coded it up recently,
every single step in the process of
building a chatbot is fresh in your RAM.
I'm curious if you had similar thoughts about,
"Oh, there was no one thing that was
relevant to going from GPT-2 to nanochat."
What are some surprising
takeaways from the experience?
Of building nanochat? So nanochat
is a repository I released.
Was it yesterday or the day
before? I can't remember.
We can see the sleep
deprivation that went into the…
It's trying to be the simplest complete
repository that covers the whole pipeline
end-to-end of building a ChatGPT clone.
So you have all of the steps, not just
any individual step, which is a bunch.
I worked on all the individual steps
in the past and released small pieces
of code that show you how that's done
in an algorithmic sense, in simple code.
But this handles the entire pipeline.
In terms of learning, I don't
know that I necessarily found
something that I learned from it.
I already had in my mind how you build it.
This is just the process of mechanically building
it and making it clean enough so that people can
learn from it and that they find it useful.
What is the best way for somebody
to learn from it?
Is it to just delete
all the code and try to reimplement from
scratch, try to add modifications to it?
That's a great question. Basically
it's about 8,000 lines of code
that takes you through the entire pipeline.
I would probably put it on the right monitor.
If you have two monitors, you put it on the right.
You want to build it from scratch,
you build it from the start.
You're not allowed to copy-paste, you're allowed
to reference, you're not allowed to copy-paste.
Maybe that's how I would do it.
But I also think the repository
by itself is a pretty large beast.
When you write this code, you don't go from top
to bottom, you go from chunks and you grow the
chunks, and that information is absent.
You wouldn't know where to start.
So it's not just a final repository that's
needed, it's the building of the repository,
which is a complicated chunk-growing process.
So that part is not there yet.
I would love to add that probably later this week.
It's probably a video or something like that.
Roughly speaking, that's what I would try to do.
Build the stuff yourself, but don't allow
yourself copy-paste.
I do think that
there's two types of knowledge, almost.
There's the high-level surface knowledge, but when
you build something from scratch, you're forced to
come to terms with what you don't understand and
you don't know that you don't understand it.
It always leads to a deeper understanding.
It's the only way to build.
If I can't build it, I don't understand it.
That’s a Feynman quote, I believe.
I 100% have always believed this very
strongly, because there are all these micro
things that are just not properly arranged
and you don't really have the knowledge.
You just think you have the knowledge.
So don't write blog posts, don't
do slides, don't do any of that.
Build the code, arrange it, get it to work.
It's the only way to go. Otherwise,
you're missing knowledge.
You tweeted out that coding models
were of very little help to you in assembling
this repository. I'm curious why that was.
I guess I built the repository over
a period of a bit more than a month.
I would say there are three major classes
of how people interact with code right now.
Some people completely reject all of LLMs
and they are just writing by scratch.
This is probably not the
right thing to do anymore.
The intermediate part, which is where I am, is
you still write a lot of things from scratch,
but you use the autocomplete that's
available now from these models.
So when you start writing out a little
piece of it, it will autocomplete for
you and you can just tap through.
Most of the time it's correct,
sometimes it's not, and you edit it.
But you're still very much the
architect of what you're writing.
Then there's the vibe coding: "Hi,
please implement this or that," enter, and then
let the model do it. That's the agents. I do feel
like the agents work in very specific settings,
and I would use them in specific settings.
But these are all tools available to you
and you have to learn what they're good at,
what they're not good at, and when to use them.
So the agents are pretty good, for example,
if you're doing boilerplate stuff.
Boilerplate code that's just
copy-paste stuff, they're very good at that.
They're very good at stuff that occurs very often
on the Internet because there are lots of examples
of it in the training sets of these models.
There are features of things where
the models will do very well.
I would say nanochat is not an example of
those because it's a fairly unique repository.
There's not that much code in the way that
I've structured it. It's not boilerplate code.
It's intellectually intense code almost, and
everything has to be very precisely arranged.
The models have so many cognitive deficits.
One example, they kept misunderstanding the code
because they have too much memory from
all the typical ways of doing things on
the Internet that I just wasn't adopting.
The models, for example—I don't know if I
want to get into the full details—but they kept
thinking I'm writing normal code, and I'm not.
Maybe one example?
You have eight GPUs
that are all doing forward, backwards.
The way to synchronize gradients between
them is to use a Distributed Data Parallel
container of PyTorch, which automatically
as you're doing the backward, it will start
communicating and synchronizing gradients.
I didn't use DDP because I didn't want
to use it, because it's not necessary.
I threw it out and wrote my own synchronization
routine that's inside the step of the optimizer.
The models were trying to get me to
use the DDP container. They were very
concerned. This gets way too technical,
but I wasn't using that container because
I don't need it and I have a custom
implementation of something like it.
They just couldn't internalize
that you had your own.
They couldn't get past that. They kept trying to
mess up the style. They're way too over-defensive.
They make all these try-catch statements.
They keep trying to make a production code base,
and I have a bunch of assumptions
in my code, and it's okay.
I don't need all this extra stuff in there.
So I feel like they're bloating the code base,
bloating the complexity, they keep
misunderstanding, they're using
deprecated APIs a bunch of times. It's a total
mess. It's just not net useful. I can go in,
I can clean it up, but it's not net useful.
I also feel like it's annoying to have to
type out what I want in English
because it's too much typing.
If I just navigate to the part of the code that I
want, and I go where I know the code has to appear
and I start typing out the first few letters,
autocomplete gets it and just gives you the code.
This is a very high information
bandwidth to specify what you want.
You point to the code where you want
it, you type out the first few pieces,
and the model will complete it.
So what I mean is, these models
are good in certain parts of the stack.
There are two examples where I use the
models that I think are illustrative.
One was when I generated the report.
That's more boilerplate-y, so I
partially vibe-coded some of that stuff.
That was fine because it's not
mission-critical stuff, and it works fine.
The other part is when I was
rewriting the tokenizer in Rust.
I'm not as good at Rust
because I'm fairly new to Rust.
So there's a bit of vibe coding going on
when I was writing some of the Rust code.
But I had a Python implementation that I
fully understand, and I'm just making sure
I'm making a more efficient version of it, and
I have tests so I feel safer doing that stuff.
They increase accessibility to languages or
paradigms that you might not be as familiar with.
I think they're very helpful there as well.
There's a ton of Rust code out there,
the models are pretty good at it.
I happen to not know that much about it,
so the models are very useful there.
The reason this question is so interesting
is because the main story people
have about AI exploding and getting
to superintelligence pretty rapidly is AI
automating AI engineering and AI research.
They'll look at the fact that you can have
Claude Code and make entire applications,
CRUD applications, from scratch and think, "If
you had this same capability inside of OpenAI
and DeepMind and everything, just imagine
a thousand of you or a million of you in
parallel, finding little architectural tweaks."
It's quite interesting to hear you say that this
is the thing they're asymmetrically worse at.
It's quite relevant to forecasting whether
the AI 2027-type explosion is
likely to happen anytime soon.
That's a good way of putting it, and you're
getting at why my timelines are a bit longer.
You're right. They're not very good at code
that has never been written before, maybe it's
one way to put it, which is what we're trying
to achieve when we're building these models.
Very naive question, but the architectural
tweaks that you're adding to nanochat,
they're in a paper somewhere, right?
They might even be in a repo somewhere.
Is it surprising that they aren't able to
integrate that into whenever you're like,
"Add RoPE embeddings" or something,
they do that in the wrong way?
It's tough. They know, but they don't fully know.
They don't know how to fully integrate it into
the repo and your style and your code and
your place, and some of the custom things
that you're doing and how it fits with
all the assumptions of the repository.
They do have some knowledge, but they
haven't gotten to the place where they
can integrate it and make sense of it.
A lot of the stuff continues to improve.
Currently, the state-of-the-art
model that I go to is the GPT-5 Pro,
and that's a very powerful model.
If I have 20 minutes,
I will copy-paste my entire repo and I go to
GPT-5 Pro, the oracle, for some questions.
Often it's not too bad and surprisingly
good compared to what existed a year ago.
Overall, the models are not there.
I feel like the industry is making too
big of a jump and is trying to pretend like this
is amazing, and it's not. It's slop. They're not
coming to terms with it, and maybe they're
trying to fundraise or something like that.
I'm not sure what's going on, but we're
at this intermediate stage. The models are
amazing. They still need a lot of work.
For now, autocomplete is my sweet spot.
But sometimes, for some types of
code, I will go to an LLM agent.
Here's another reason this is really interesting.
Through the history of programming, there have
been many productivity improvements—compilers,
linting, better programming languages—which
have increased programmer productivity
but have not led to an explosion.
That sounds very much like the
autocomplete tab, and this other
category is just automation of the programmer.
It's interesting you're seeing more in the
category of the historical analogies
of better compilers or something.
Maybe this gets to one other thought.
I have a hard time differentiating where
AI begins and stops because I see
AI as fundamentally an extension of
computing in a pretty fundamental way.
I see a continuum of this recursive
self-improvement or speeding up programmers
all the way from the beginning: code editors,
syntax highlighting, or checking even of
the types, like data type checking—all
these tools that we've built for
each other. Even search engines.
Why aren't search engines part of AI? Ranking
is AI. At some point, Google, even early on,
was thinking of themselves as an AI company doing
Google Search engine, which is totally fair.
I see it as a lot more of a continuum than other
people do, and it's hard for me to draw the line.
I feel like we're now getting a much
better autocomplete, and now we're also
getting some agents which are these loopy
things, but they go off-rails sometimes.
What's going on is that the human is progressively
doing a bit less and less of the low-level stuff.
We're not writing the assembly
code because we have compilers.
Compilers will take my high-level
language in C and write the assembly code.
We're abstracting ourselves very, very slowly.
There's this what I call "autonomy slider," where
more and more stuff is automated—of the stuff that
can be automated at any point in time—and we're
doing a bit less and less and raising ourselves
in the layer of abstraction over the automation.
Let's talk about RL a bit.
You tweeted some very
interesting things about this.
Conceptually, how should we think about
the way that humans are able to build a rich world
model just from interacting with our environment,
and in ways that seem almost irrespective of
the final reward at the end of the episode?
If somebody is starting a business, and at
the end of 10 years, she finds out whether
the business succeeded or failed, we say that
she's earned a bunch of wisdom and experience.
But it's not because the log probs of every
single thing that happened over the last 10
years are up-weighted or down-weighted.
Something much more deliberate and
rich is happening.
What is the ML analogy, and how does that
compare to what we're doing with LLMs right now?
Maybe the way I would put it is that humans don't
use reinforcement learning, as I said.
I think they do something different.
Reinforcement learning is a lot worse than I
think the average person thinks. Reinforcement
learning is terrible. It just so happens
that everything that we had before it is
much worse because previously we were just
imitating people, so it has all these issues.
In reinforcement learning, say you're solving
a math problem, because it's very simple.
You're given a math problem and
you're trying to find the solution.
In reinforcement learning, you will
try lots of things in parallel first.
You're given a problem, you try hundreds of
different attempts. These attempts can be complex.
They can be like, "Oh, let me try this, let me try
that, this didn't work, that didn't work," etc.
Then maybe you get an answer.
Now you check the back of the book and you see,
"Okay, the correct answer is this."
You can see that this one, this one,
and that one got the correct answer,
but these other 97 of them didn't.
Literally what reinforcement learning does is it
goes to the ones that worked really well and every
single thing you did along the way, every single
token gets upweighted like, "Do more of this."
The problem with that is people will say
that your estimator has high variance,
but it's just noisy. It's noisy. It almost assumes
that every single little piece of the solution
that you made that arrived at the right answer
was the correct thing to do, which is not true.
You may have gone down the wrong alleys
until you arrived at the right solution.
Every single one of those incorrect things you
did, as long as you got to the correct solution,
will be upweighted as, "Do more of this."
It's terrible. It's noise. You've done all
this work only to find, at the end, you get a
single number of like, "Oh, you did correct."
Based on that, you weigh that entire
trajectory as like, upweight or downweight.
The way I like to put it is you're
sucking supervision through a straw.
You've done all this work that
could be a minute of rollout,
and you're sucking the bits of supervision of the
final reward signal through a straw and you're
broadcasting that across the entire trajectory
and using that to upweight or downweight that
trajectory. It's just stupid and
crazy. A human would never do this.
Number one, a human would
never do hundreds of rollouts.
Number two, when a person finds a solution,
they will have a pretty complicated process
of review of, "Okay, I think these parts I
did well, these parts I did not do that well.
I should probably do this or that."
They think through things. There's
nothing in current LLMs that does this.
There's no equivalent of it. But I do see
papers popping out that are trying to do this
because it's obvious to everyone in the field.
The first imitation learning, by the way, was
extremely surprising and miraculous and amazing,
that we can fine-tune by imitation on humans.
That was incredible. Because in the beginning,
all we had was base models. Base models
are autocomplete. It wasn't obvious to
me at the time, and I had to learn this.
The paper that blew my mind was InstructGPT,
because it pointed out that you can take
the pretrained model, which is autocomplete,
and if you just fine-tune it on text that looks
like conversations, the model will very rapidly
adapt to become very conversational, and it
keeps all the knowledge from pre-training.
This blew my mind because I didn't understand
that stylistically, it can adjust so quickly
and become an assistant to a user through just
a few loops of fine-tuning on that kind of data.
It was very miraculous to me that that worked.
So incredible. That was two to three years of
work. Now came RL. And RL allows you to do a bit
better than just imitation learning because you
can have these reward functions and you
can hill-climb on the reward functions.
Some problems have just correct answers, you
can hill-climb on that without getting expert
trajectories to imitate. So that's amazing. The
model can also discover solutions that a human
might never come up with. This is incredible.
Yet, it's still stupid. We need more. I saw a
paper from Google yesterday that tried to
have this reflect & review idea in mind.
Was it the memory bank paper or something? I don't
know. I've seen a few papers along these lines.
So I expect there to be some major update to how
we do algorithms for LLMs coming in that realm.
I think we need three or four or
five more, something like that.
You're so good at coming up with evocative
phrases. "Sucking supervision through a
straw." It's so good. You're saying the problem
with outcome-based reward is that you have this
huge trajectory, and then at the end, you're
trying to learn every single possible thing
about what you should do and what you should
learn about the world from that one final bit.
Given the fact that this is obvious, why hasn't
process-based supervision as an alternative been
a successful way to make models more capable?
What has been preventing us from using
this alternative paradigm?
Process-based supervision just
refers to the fact that we're not going to
have a reward function only at the very end.
After you've done 10 minutes of work, I'm not
going to tell you you did well or not well.
I'm going to tell you at every single
step of the way how well you're doing.
The reason we don't have that is
it's tricky how you do that properly.
You have partial solutions and you
don't know how to assign credit.
So when you get the right answer, it's just
an equality match to the answer. It’s very
simple to implement. If you're doing process
supervision, how do you assign in an automatable
way, a partial credit assignment?
It's not obvious how you do it.
Lots of labs are trying to
do it with these LLM judges.
You get LLMs to try to do it.
You prompt an LLM, "Hey,
look at a partial solution of a student.
How well do you think they're doing if the
answer is this?" and they try to tune the prompt.
The reason that this is tricky is quite subtle.
It's the fact that anytime you use an LLM to
assign a reward, those LLMs are giant things
with billions of parameters, and they're gameable.
If you're reinforcement learning with respect to
them, you will find adversarial examples
for your LLM judges, almost guaranteed.
So you can't do this for too long.
You do maybe 10 steps or 20 steps, and maybe
it will work, but you can't do 100 or 1,000.
I understand it's not obvious, but basically
the model will find little cracks.
It will find all these spurious
things in the nooks and crannies of the
giant model and find a way to cheat it.
One example that's prominently in my mind, this
was probably public, if you're using an LLM judge
for a reward, you just give it a solution from a
student and ask it if the student did well or not.
We were training with
reinforcement learning against
that reward function, and it worked really well.
Then, suddenly, the reward became extremely large.
It was a massive jump, and it did perfect.
You're looking at it like, "Wow, this means
the student is perfect in all these problems.
It's fully solved math." But when you look at
the completions that you're getting from
the model, they are complete nonsense.
They start out okay, and then
they change to "dhdhdhdh."
It's just like, "Oh, okay, let's take two plus
three and we do this and this, and then dhdhdhdh."
You're looking at it, and
it's like, this is crazy.
How is it getting a reward of one or 100%?
You look at the LLM judge, and it turns out
that "dhdhdhdh" is an adversarial example for
the model, and it assigns 100% probability to it.
It's just because this is an
out-of-sample example to the LLM.
It's never seen it during training,
and you're in pure generalization land.
It's never seen it during training, and in
the pure generalization land, you can find
these examples that break it.
You're basically training
the LLM to be a prompt injection model.
Not even that. Prompt injection is way too fancy.
You're finding adversarial
examples, as they're called.
These are nonsensical solutions that are obviously
wrong, but the model thinks they are amazing.
To the extent you think this is the
bottleneck to making RL more functional,
then that will require making LLMs better judges,
if you want to do this in an automated way.
Is it just going to be some sort
of GAN-like approach where you
have to train models to be more robust?
The labs are probably doing all that.
The obvious thing is, "dhdhdhdh"
should not get 100% reward.
Okay, well, take "dhdhdhdh," put it
in the training set of the LLM judge,
and say this is not 100%, this is 0%.
You can do this, but every time you do
this, you get a new LLM, and it
still has adversarial examples.
There's an infinity of adversarial examples.
Probably if you iterate this a few times, it'll
probably be harder and harder to find adversarial
examples, but I'm not 100% sure because this thing
has a trillion parameters or whatnot.
I bet you the labs are trying.
I still think we need other ideas.
Interesting. Do you have some shape
of what the other idea could be?
This idea of a review solution
encompassing synthetic examples such that
when you train on them, you get better,
and meta-learn it in some way.
I think there are some papers
that I'm starting to see pop out.
I am only at a stage of reading abstracts
because a lot of these papers are just ideas.
Someone has to make it work on a frontier
LLM lab scale in full generality
because when you see these papers,
they pop up, and it's just a bit noisy.
They're cool ideas, but I haven't seen
anyone convincingly show that this is possible.
That said, the LLM labs are fairly closed,
so who knows what they're doing now.
I can conceptualize how you would be able
to train on synthetic examples or synthetic
problems that you have made for yourself.
But there seems to be another thing humans
do—maybe sleep is this, maybe daydreaming is
this—which is not necessarily to come up
with fake problems, but just to reflect.
I'm not sure what the ML analogy is for
daydreaming or sleeping, or just reflecting.
I haven't come up with a new problem.
Obviously, the very basic analogy would just
be fine-tuning on reflection bits, but I feel like
in practice that probably wouldn't work that well.
Do you have some take on what
the analogy of this thing is?
I do think that we're missing some aspects there.
As an example, let’s take reading a book.
Currently when LLMs are reading a book, what that
means is we stretch out the sequence of text,
and the model is predicting the next token,
and it's getting some knowledge from that.
That's not really what humans do.
When you're reading a book,
I don't even feel like the book is exposition
I'm supposed to be attending to and training on.
The book is a set of prompts for
me to do synthetic data generation,
or for you to get to a book club
and talk about it with your friends.
It's by manipulating that information
that you actually gain that knowledge.
We have no equivalent of that with LLMs. They
don't really do that. I'd love to see during
pre-training some stage that thinks through
the material and tries to reconcile it with
what it already knows, and thinks through it
for some amount of time and gets that to work.
There's no equivalence of any of this.
This is all research. There are some
subtle—very subtle that I think are very hard
to understand—reasons why it's not trivial.
If I can just describe one: why can't we
just synthetically generate and train on it?
Because every synthetic example, if
I just give synthetic generation of
the model thinking about a book, you look
at it and you're like, "This looks great.
Why can't I train on it?"
You could try, but the model
will get much worse if you continue trying.
That's because all of the samples you get
from models are silently collapsed.
Silently—it is not obvious if you look
at any individual example of it—they occupy
a very tiny manifold of the possible space of
thoughts about content.
The LLMs, when they come off,
they're what we call "collapsed."
They have a collapsed data distribution.
One easy way to see it is to go to
ChatGPT and ask it, "Tell me a joke."
It only has like three jokes.
It's not giving you the whole breadth
of possible jokes. It knows like three jokes.
They're silently collapsed. You're not getting
the richness and the diversity and the entropy
from these models as you would get from humans.
Humans are a lot noisier, but
at least they're not biased,
in a statistical sense. They're not silently
collapsed. They maintain a huge amount of entropy.
So how do you get synthetic data generation to
work despite the collapse and while maintaining
the entropy? That’s a research problem.
Just to make sure I understood, the reason
that the collapse is relevant to synthetic data
generation is because you want to be able to
come up with synthetic problems or reflections
which are not already in your data distribution?
I guess what I'm saying is, say we have a chapter
of a book and I ask an LLM to think about it,
it will give you something
that looks very reasonable.
But if I ask it 10 times, you'll
notice that all of them are the same.
You can't just keep scaling "reflection"
on the same amount of prompt information
and then get returns from that.
Any individual sample will look okay,
but the distribution of it is quite terrible.
It's quite terrible in such a way that if
you continue training on too much of
your own stuff, you actually collapse.
I think that there's possibly
no fundamental solution to this.
I also think humans collapse over time.
These analogies are surprisingly good.
Humans collapse during the course of their lives.
This is why children, they haven't overfit yet.
They will say stuff that will shock you
because you can see where they're coming from,
but it's just not the thing people say,
because they're not yet collapsed. But we're
collapsed. We end up revisiting the same thoughts.
We end up saying more and more of the same stuff,
and the learning rates go down, and
the collapse continues to get worse,
and then everything deteriorates.
Have you seen this super interesting
paper that dreaming is a way of preventing
this kind of overfitting and collapse?
The reason dreaming is evolutionary adaptive
is to put you in weird situations that are
very unlike your day-to-day reality, so
as to prevent this kind of overfitting.
It's an interesting idea. I do think
that when you're generating things
in your head and then you're attending to
it, you're training on your own samples,
you're training on your synthetic data.
If you do it for too long,
you go off-rails and you collapse way too much.
You always have to seek entropy in your life.
Talking to other people is a great
source of entropy, and things like that.
So maybe the brain has also built some internal
mechanisms for increasing the amount of entropy
in that process. That's an interesting idea.
This is a very ill-formed thought so I’ll
just put it out and let you react to it.
The best learners that we are aware of,
which are children, are extremely
bad at recollecting information.
In fact, at the very earliest stages of
childhood, you will forget everything.
You're just an amnesiac about everything
that happens before a certain year date.
But you're extremely good at picking up
new languages and learning from the world.
Maybe there's some element of being
able to see the forest for the trees.
Whereas if you compare it to the opposite end
of the spectrum, you have LLM pre-training,
where these models will literally be
able to regurgitate word-for-word what
is the next thing in a Wikipedia page.
But their ability to learn abstract
concepts really quickly, the way
a child can, is much more limited.
Then adults are somewhere in between, where
they don't have the flexibility of childhood
learning, but they can memorize facts and
information in a way that is harder for kids.
I don't know if there's something
interesting about that spectrum.
I think there's something very
interesting about that, 100%.
I do think that humans have a lot more of
an element, compared to LLMs, of seeing
the forest for the trees.
We're not actually that good
at memorization, which is actually a feature.
Because we're not that good at memorization, we're
forced to find patterns in a more general sense.
LLMs in comparison are extremely good
at memorization.
They will recite
passages from all these training sources.
You can give them completely nonsensical data.
You can hash some amount of text or something
like that, you get a completely random sequence.
If you train on it, even just for a single
iteration or two, it can suddenly regurgitate
the entire thing. It will memorize it.
There's no way a person can read a single
sequence of random numbers and recite it to you.
That's a feature, not a bug, because it forces
you to only learn the generalizable components.
Whereas LLMs are distracted by all the memory
that they have of the pre-training
documents, and it's probably very
distracting to them in a certain sense.
So that's why when I talk about the
cognitive core, I want to remove the
memory, which is what we talked about.
I'd love to have them have less memory
so that they have to look things up,
and they only maintain the algorithms for
thought, and the idea of an experiment,
and all this cognitive glue of acting.
And this is also relevant to preventing
model collapse?
Let me think. I'm
not sure. It's almost like a separate axis.
The models are way too good at memorization,
and somehow we should remove that.
People are much worse, but it's a good thing.
What is a solution to model collapse?
There are very naive things you could attempt.
The distribution over logits
should be wider or something.
There are many naive things you could try.
What ends up being the problem
with the naive approaches?
That's a great question. You can imagine having
a regularization for entropy and things like that.
I guess they just don't work as well empirically
because right now the models are collapsed.
But I will say most of the tasks that we
want from them don't actually demand diversity.
That’s probably the answer to what's going on.
The frontier labs are trying
to make the models useful.
I feel like the diversity of
the outputs is not so much...
Number one, it's much harder to work with and
evaluate and all this stuff, but maybe it's not
what's capturing most of the value.
In fact, it's actively penalized.
If you're super creative in RL, it's not good.
Yeah. Or maybe if you're doing a lot of writing,
help from LLMs and stuff like that, it's probably
bad because the models will silently give
you all the same stuff.
They won't explore lots
of different ways of answering a question.
Maybe this diversity, not as many applications
need it so the models don't have it.
But then it's a problem at
synthetic data generation time, et cetera.
So we're shooting ourselves in the foot by not
allowing this entropy to maintain in the model.
Possibly the labs should try harder.
I think you hinted that it's a very
fundamental problem, it won't be easy
to solve. What's your intuition for that?
I don't know if it's super fundamental.
I don't know if I intended to say that.
I do think that I haven't done these experiments,
but I do think that you could probably
regularize the entropy to be higher.
So you're encouraging the model to give you more
and more solutions, but you don't want it to
start deviating too much from the training data.
It's going to start making up its own language.
It's going to start using words that are
extremely rare, so it's going to drift too
much from the distribution.
So I think controlling
the distribution is just tricky.
It's probably not trivial in that sense.
How many bits should the optimal core
of intelligence end up being if you
just had to make a guess?
The thing we put on the
von Neumann probes, how big does it have to be?
It's really interesting in the history of the
field because at one point everything was
very scaling-pilled in terms of like, "Oh,
we're gonna make much bigger models,
trillions of parameter models."
What the models have done in size
is they've gone up and now they've
come down. State-of-the-art models are smaller.
Even then, I think they memorized way too much.
So I had a prediction a while back that I almost
feel like we can get cognitive cores that are
very good at even a billion parameters.
If you talk to a billion parameter model,
I think in 20 years, you can have
a very productive conversation.
It thinks and it's a lot more like a human.
But if you ask it some factual question, it might
have to look it up, but it knows that it doesn't
know and it might have to look it up and it will
just do all the reasonable things.
That's surprising that you think
it'll take a billion parameters.
Because already we have billion
parameter models or a couple billion
parameter models that are very intelligent.
Well, state-of-the-art models
are like a trillion parameters.
But they remember so much stuff.
Yeah, but I'm surprised that in 10 years,
given the pace… We have gpt-oss-20b.
That's way better than GPT-4 original,
which was a trillion plus parameters.
Given that trend, I'm surprised you
think in 10 years the cognitive
core is still a billion parameters.
I'm surprised you're not like, "Oh it's
gonna be like tens of millions or millions."
Here's the issue, the training data is
the internet, which is really terrible.
There's a huge amount of gains to be
made because the internet is terrible.
Even the internet, when you and I think of
the internet, you're thinking of like The
Wall Street Journal. That's not what this
is. When you're looking at a pre-training
dataset in the frontier lab and you look at a
random internet document, it's total garbage.
I don't even know how this works at all.
It's some like stock tickers, symbols,
it's a huge amount of slop and garbage
from like all the corners of the internet.
It's not like your Wall Street Journal
article, that's extremely rare.
So because the internet is so terrible, we have
to build really big models to compress all that.
Most of that compression is memory
work instead of cognitive work.
But what we really want is the
cognitive part, delete the memory.
I guess what I'm saying is that we need
intelligent models to help us refine even
the pre-training set to just narrow
it down to the cognitive components.
Then I think you get away with a
much smaller model because it's a
much better dataset and you could train it on it.
But probably it's not trained directly on it, it's
probably distilled from a much better model still.
But why is the distilled version still a billion?
I just feel like distillation
works extremely well.
So almost every small model, if you have a
small model, it's almost certainly distilled.
Right, but why is the distillation in
10 years not getting below 1 billion?
Oh, you think it should be smaller than a
billion? I mean, come on, right? I don't
know. At some point it should take at least
a billion knobs to do something interesting.
You're thinking it should be even smaller?
Yeah. If you look at the trend over the last
few years of just finding low-hanging fruit and
going from trillion plus models to models that
are literally two orders of magnitude smaller in a
matter of two years and having better performance,
it makes me think the sort of core of
intelligence might be even way, way smaller.
Plenty of room at the bottom,
to paraphrase Feynman.
I feel like I'm already contrarian
by talking about a billion parameter
cognitive core and you're outdoing me.
Maybe we could get a little bit smaller.
I do think that practically speaking, you
want the model to have some knowledge.
You don't want it to be looking up everything
because then you can't think in your head.
You're looking up way too much stuff all the time.
Some basic curriculum needs to be there for
knowledge, but it doesn't have esoteric knowledge.
We're discussing what plausibly
could be the cognitive core.
There's a separate question which is what
will be the size of frontier models over time?
I'm curious if you have predictions.
We had increasing scale up to maybe GPT 4.5 and
now we're seeing decreasing or plateauing scale.
There are many reasons this could be going on.
Do you have a prediction going forward?
Will the biggest models be bigger,
will they be smaller, will they be the same?
I don't have a super strong prediction.
The labs are just being practical.
They have a flops budget and a cost budget.
It just turns out that pre-training is not where
you want to put most of your flops or your cost.
That's why the models have gotten smaller.
They are a bit smaller, the pre-training
stage is smaller, but they make
it up in reinforcement learning,
mid-training, and all this stuff that follows.
They're just being practical in terms of all the
stages and how you get the most bang for the buck.
Forecasting that trend is quite hard.
I do still expect that there's so much
low-hanging fruit. That's my basic expectation.
I have a very wide distribution here.
Do you expect the low-hanging fruit to be
similar in kind to the kinds of things that have
been happening over the last two to five years?
If I look at nanochat versus nanoGPT
and the architectural tweaks you made,
is that the flavor of things you
expect to continue to keep happening?
You're not expecting any giant paradigm shifts.
For the most part, yeah. I expect the
datasets to get much, much better.
When you look at the average datasets,
they're extremely terrible.
They’re so bad that I
don't even know how anything works.
Look at the average example in the training set:
factual mistakes, errors, nonsensical things.
Somehow when you do it at scale,
the noise washes away and you're left with
some of the signal. Datasets will improve
a ton. Everything gets better. Our hardware,
all the kernels for running the hardware and
maximizing what you get with the hardware.
Nvidia is slowly tuning the hardware itself,
Tensor Cores, all that needs to
happen and will continue to happen.
All the kernels will get better and
utilize the chip to the max extent.
All the algorithms will probably improve over
optimization, architecture, and all the modeling
components of how everything is done and what
the algorithms are that we're even training with.
I do expect that nothing dominates. Everything
plus 20%. This is roughly what I've seen.
People have proposed different ways of charting
how much progress we've made towards full AGI.
If you can come up with some line, then you
can see where that line intersects with AGI
and where that would happen on the x-axis.
People have proposed it's the education level.
We had a high schooler, and then they went to
college with RL, and they're going to get a Ph.D.
I don't like that one.
Or they'll propose horizon
length. Maybe they can do tasks that take
a minute, they can do those autonomously.
Then they can autonomously do tasks that take
an hour, a human an hour, a human a week.
How do you think about the relevant y-axis here?
How should we think about how
AI is making progress?
I have two answers to that.
Number one, I'm almost tempted to
reject the question entirely because
I see this as an extension of computing.
Have we talked about how to chart progress
in computing, or how do you chart progress
in computing since the 1970s or whatever?
What is the y-axis? The whole question is
funny from that perspective a little bit.
When people talk about AI and the original AGI
and how we spoke about it when OpenAI started,
AGI was a system you could go to that can do any
economically valuable task at human performance
or better. That was the definition. I
was pretty happy with that at the time.
I've stuck to that definition forever, and
then people have made up all kinds of other
definitions. But I like that definition. The first
concession that people make all the time is they
just take out all the physical stuff because
we're just talking about digital knowledge work.
That's a pretty major concession compared to
the original definition, which was any task
a human can do. I can lift things, etc. AI
can't do that, obviously, but we'll take it.
What fraction of the economy are we taking away
by saying, "Oh, only knowledge work?" I don't know
the numbers. I feel about 10% to 20%, if I had to
guess, is only knowledge work, someone could work
from home and perform tasks, something like that.
It's still a really large market.
What is the size of the
economy, and what is 10% or 20%?
We're still talking about a few trillion
dollars, even in the US, of market share or work.
So it's still a very massive bucket.
Going back to the definition,
what I would be looking for is to
what extent is that definition true?
Are there jobs or lots of tasks?
If we think of tasks as not jobs but tasks.
It's difficult because the problem is society will
refactor based on the tasks that make up jobs,
based on what's automatable or not.
Today, what jobs are replaceable by AI?
A good example recently was Geoff Hinton's
prediction that radiologists would not be
a job anymore, and this turned out
to be very wrong in a bunch of ways.
Radiologists are alive and well and growing,
even though computer vision is really,
really good at recognizing all the different
things that they have to recognize in images.
It's just a messy, complicated job with a
lot of surfaces and dealing with patients
and all this stuff in the context of it.
I don't know that by that definition
AI has made a huge dent yet.
Some of the jobs that I would
be looking for have some features that make it
very amenable to automation earlier than later.
As an example, call center employees
often come up, and I think rightly so.
Call center employees have a number of simplifying
properties with respect to what's automatable
today. Their jobs are pretty simple. It's a
sequence of tasks, and every task looks similar.
You take a phone call with a person, it's
10 minutes of interaction or whatever it is,
probably a bit longer.
In my experience, a lot longer.
You complete some task in some scheme,
and you change some database entries
around or something like that.
So you keep repeating something
over and over again, and that's your job.
You do want to bring in the task horizon—how
long it takes to perform a task—and
then you want to also remove context.
You're not dealing with different parts of
services of companies or other customers.
It's just the database, you,
and a person you're serving.
It's more closed, it's more
understandable, it's purely digital.
So I would be looking for those things.
But even there, I'm not looking
at full automation yet.
I'm looking for an autonomy slider.
I expect that we are not going
to instantly replace people.
We're going to be swapping in
AIs that do 80% of the volume.
They delegate 20% of the volume to humans,
and humans are supervising teams of five AIs
doing the call center work that's more rote.
I would be looking for new interfaces or new
companies that provide some
layer that allows you to manage
some of these AIs that are not yet perfect.
Then I would expect that across the economy.
A lot of jobs are a lot harder
than a call center employee.
With radiologists, I'm totally
speculating and I have no idea what
the actual workflow of a radiologist involves.
But one analogy that might be applicable is when
Waymos were first being rolled out, there'd be a
person sitting in the front seat, and you just had
to have them there to make sure that if something
went really wrong, they're there to monitor.
Even today, people are still watching
to make sure things are going well.
Robotaxi, which was just deployed,
still has a person inside it.
Now we could be in a similar situation where
if you automate 99% of a job, that last 1%
the human has to do is incredibly valuable
because it's bottlenecking everything else.
If it were the case with radiologists, where
the person sitting in the front of Waymo has
to be specially trained for years in order
to provide the last 1%, their wages should
go up tremendously because they're the
one thing bottlenecking wide deployment.
Radiologists, I think their wages have
gone up for similar reasons, if you're
the last bottleneck and you're not fungible.
A Waymo driver might be fungible with others.
So you might see this thing where your wages
go up until you get to 99% and then fall just
like that when the last 1% is gone.
And I wonder if we're seeing similar
things with radiology or salaries of call
center workers or anything like that.
That's an interesting question. I don't think
we're currently seeing that with radiology.
I think radiology is not a good example.
I don't know why Geoff Hinton picked
on radiology because I think it's an
extremely messy, complicated profession.
I would be a lot more interested in what's
happening with call center employees today,
for example, because I would expect a lot
of the rote stuff to be automatable today.
I don't have first-level access to it but
I would be looking for trends of what's
happening with the call center employees.
Some of the things I would also expect
is that maybe they are swapping in AI, but
then I would still wait for a year or two
because I would potentially expect them to
pull back and rehire some of the people.
There's been evidence that that's already been
happening generally in companies that have been
adopting AI, which I think is quite surprising.
I also found what was really surprising. AGI,
right? A thing which would do everything.
We'll take out physical work,
but it should be able to do all knowledge work.
What you would have naively anticipated is that
the way this progression would happen is
that you take a little task that a consultant
is doing, you take that out of the bucket.
You take a little task that an accountant is
doing, you take that out of the bucket.
Then you're just doing this
across all knowledge work.
But instead, if we do believe we're
on the path of AGI with the current paradigm,
the progression is very much not like that.
It does not seem like consultants and accountants
are getting huge productivity improvements.
It's very much like programmers are getting
more and more chiseled away at their work.
If you look at the revenues of these companies,
discounting normal chat revenue—which is similar
to Google or something—just looking at
API revenues, it's dominated by coding.
So this thing which is "general", which
should be able to do any knowledge work,
is just overwhelmingly doing only coding.
It's a surprising way that you would
expect the AGI to be deployed.
There's an interesting point
here. I do believe coding is the perfect
first thing for these LLMs and agents.
That’s because coding has always
fundamentally worked around text.
It's computer terminals and text,
and everything is based around text.
LLMs, the way they're trained
on the Internet, love text.
They're perfect text processors, and there's
all this data out there. It's a perfect fit.
We also have a lot of infrastructure
pre-built for handling code and text.
For example, we have Visual Studio Code
or your favorite IDE showing you code,
and an agent can plug into that.
If an agent has a diff where it made some change,
we suddenly have all this code already that shows
all the differences to a code base using a diff.
It's almost like we've pre-built a
lot of the infrastructure for code.
Contrast that with some of the
things that don't enjoy that at all.
As an example, there are people trying to build
automation not for coding, but for slides.
I saw a company doing slides. That's
much, much harder. The reason it's
much harder is because slides are not text.
Slides are little graphics, they're arranged
spatially, and there's a visual component to it.
Slides don't have this pre-built infrastructure.
For example, if an agent is to make a change to
your slides, how does a thing show you the diff?
How do you see the diff?
There's nothing that shows diffs
for slides. Someone has to build it. Some of these
things are not amenable to AIs as they are, which
are text processors, and code surprisingly is.
I’m not sure that alone explains it.
I personally have tried to get LLMs to be useful
in domains which are just pure language-in,
language-out, like rewriting transcripts,
coming up with clips based on transcripts.
It's very plausible that I didn't do
every single possible thing I could do.
I put a bunch of good examples in context, but
maybe I should have done some kind of fine-tuning.
Our mutual friend, Andy Matuschak, told me that
he tried 50 billion things to try to get models
to be good at writing spaced repetition prompts.
Again, very much language-in, language-out tasks,
the kind of thing that should be dead
center in the repertoire of these LLMs.
He tried in-context learning
with a few-shot examples.
He tried supervised fine-tuning and retrieval.
He could not get them to make
cards to his satisfaction.
So I find it striking that even in language-out
domains, it's very hard to get a lot of economic
value out of these models separate from coding.
I don't know what explains it.
That makes sense. I'm not
saying that anything text is trivial.
I do think that code is pretty structured.
Text is maybe a lot more flowery, and there's
a lot more entropy in text, I would say.
I don't know how else to put it.
Also code is hard, and so people feel quite
empowered by LLMs, even from simple knowledge.
I don't know that I have a very good answer.
Obviously, text makes it much, much easier,
but it doesn't mean that all text is trivial.
How do you think about superintelligence?
Do you expect it to feel qualitatively different
from normal humans or human companies?
I see it as a progression
of automation in society.
Extrapolating the trend of computing, there will
be a gradual automation of a lot of things, and
superintelligence will an extrapolation of that.
We expect more and more autonomous
entities over time that are doing a lot
of the digital work and then eventually even
the physical work some amount of time later.
Basically I see it as just
automation, roughly speaking.
But automation includes the things humans
can already do, and superintelligence
implies things humans can’t do.
But one of the things that people
do is invent new things, which I would just
put into the automation if that makes sense.
But I guess, less abstractly and more
qualitatively, do you expect something
to feel like… Because this thing can either think
so fast, or has so many copies, or the copies can
merge back into themselves, or is much smarter,
any number of advantages an AI might have, will
the civilization in which these AIs exist
just feel qualitatively different from humans?
I think it will. It is fundamentally automation,
but it will be extremely foreign. It will look
really strange. Like you mentioned, we can run
all of this on a computer cluster and much faster.
Some of the scenarios that I start to get
nervous about when the world looks like
that is this gradual loss of control
and understanding of what's happening.
I think that's the most likely outcome, that
there will be a gradual loss of understanding.
We'll gradually layer all this stuff
everywhere, and there will be fewer
and fewer people who understand it.
Then there will be a gradual loss of
control and understanding of what's happening.
That to me seems the most likely outcome of how
all this stuff will go down.
Let me probe on that a bit.
It's not clear to me that loss of control and
loss of understanding are the same things.
A board of directors at TSMC, Intel—name a random
company—they're just prestigious 80-year-olds.
They have very little understanding, and maybe
they don't practically actually have control.
A better example
is the President of the United States.
The President has a lot of fucking power.
I'm not trying to make a good statement
about the current operant, or maybe I am,
but the actual level of understanding is
very different from the level of control.
I think that's fair. That's a good
pushback. I think I expect loss of both.
How come? Loss of understanding is
obvious, but why loss of control?
We're really far into a territory where I
don't know what this looks like, but if I
were to write sci-fi novels, they would look along
the lines of not even a single entity that takes
over everything, but multiple competing entities
that gradually become more and more autonomous.
Some of them go rogue and
the others fight them off.
It's this hot pot of completely autonomous
activity that we've delegated to.
I feel it would have that flavor.
It is not the fact that they are smarter
than us that is resulting in the loss of control.
It's the fact that they are competing with each
other, and whatever arises out of that
competition leads to the loss of control.
A lot of these things, they will be
tools to people, they're acting on
behalf of people or something like that.
So maybe those people are in control,
but maybe it's a loss of control overall for
society in the sense of outcomes we want.
You have entities acting on behalf of individuals
that are still roughly seen as out of control.
This is a question I should have asked earlier.
We were talking about how currently it feels like
when you're doing AI engineering or AI research,
these models are more in the category of compiler
rather than in the category of a replacement.
At some point, if you have AGI,
it should be able to do what you do.
Do you feel like having a million
copies of you in parallel results in
some huge speed-up of AI progress?
If that does happen, do you expect to see an
intelligence explosion once we have a true AGI?
I'm not talking about LLMs today.
I do, but it's business as usual because
we're in an intelligence explosion
already and have been for decades.
It's basically the GDP curve that is
an exponential weighted sum over so
many aspects of the industry.
Everything is gradually being
automated and has been for hundreds of years.
The Industrial Revolution is automation and
some of the physical components and
tool building and all this stuff.
Compilers are early software
automation, et cetera.
We've been recursively self-improving
and exploding for a long time.
Another way to see it is that Earth was a pretty
boring place if you don't look at the biomechanics
and so on, and looked very similar.
If you look from space, we're in the
middle of this firecracker event,
but we're seeing it in slow motion.
I definitely feel like this has
already happened for a very long time.
Again, I don't see AI as a distinct
technology with respect to what has
already been happening for a long time.
You think it's continuous with this
hyper-exponential trend?
Yes. That's why this was
very interesting to me, because I was
trying to find AI in the GDP for a while.
I thought that GDP should go up.
But then I looked at some of the
other technologies that I thought
were very transformative, like
computers or mobile phones or et cetera.
You can't find them in GDP. GDP is the same
exponential. Even the early iPhone didn't have the
App Store, and it didn't have a lot of the bells
and whistles that the modern iPhone has.
So even though we think of 2008,
when the iPhone came out, as this major
seismic change, it's actually not.
Everything is so spread out and it so
slowly diffuses that everything ends up
being averaged up into the same exponential.
It's the exact same thing with computers.
You can't find them in the GDP
like, "Oh, we have computers now."
That's not what happened, because
it's such slow progression.
With AI we're going to see the exact same thing.
It's just more automation. It allows us to write
different kinds of programs that we couldn't write
before, but AI is still fundamentally a program.
It's a new kind of computer and
a new kind of computing system.
But it has all these problems,
it's going to diffuse over time,
and it's still going to add
up to the same exponential.
We're still going to have an exponential
that's going to get extremely vertical.
It's going to be very foreign to
live in that kind of an environment.
Are you saying that, if you look at the trend
before the Industrial Revolution to now,
you have a hyper-exponential where you go
from 0% growth to then 10,000 years ago,
0.02% growth, and to now when we're at 2%
growth. That's a hyper-exponential. Are you
saying if you're charting AI on there, then
AI takes you to 20% growth or 200% growth?
Or are you saying that if you look at
the last 300 years, what you've been
seeing is that you have technology after
technology—computers, electrification,
steam engines, railways, et cetera—but the
rate of growth is the exact same, it's 2%.
Are you saying the rate of growth will go up?
The rate of growth has also stayed
roughly constant, right?
Only over the last 200, 300 years.
But over the course of
human history it's exploded.
It's gone from 0% to faster, faster,
faster. Industrial explosion, 2%.
For a while I tried to find AI
or look for AI in the GDP curve,
and I've convinced myself that this is false.
Even when people talk about recursive
self-improvement and labs and stuff
like that, this is business as usual.
Of course it's going to recursively self-improve,
and it's been recursively self-improving.
LLMs allow the engineers to work much more
efficiently to build the next round of LLM,
and a lot more of the components are
being automated and tuned and et cetera.
All the engineers having access
to Google Search is part of it.
All the engineers having an IDE, all of them
having autocomplete or having Claude code,
et cetera, it's all just part of the same
speed-up of the whole thing. It's just so smooth.
Just to clarify, you're saying that
the rate of growth will not change.
The intelligence explosion will show up as
it just enabled us to continue staying on the
2% growth trajectory, just as the Internet
helped us stay on the 2% growth trajectory.
Yes, my expectation is that
it stays in the same pattern.
Just to throw the opposite argument against you,
my expectation is that it blows up because I think
true AGI—and I'm not talking about LLM coding
bots, I'm talking about actual replacement of a
human in a server—is qualitatively different
from these other productivity-improving
technologies because it's labor itself.
I think we live in a very labor-constrained world.
If you talk to any startup founder or any person,
you can be like, what do you need more of? You
need really talented people. And if you have
billions of extra people who are inventing stuff,
integrating themselves, making companies bottom
start to finish, that feels qualitatively
different from a single technology.
It's as if you get 10 billion
extra people on the planet.
Maybe a counterpoint. I'm pretty willing
to be convinced one way or another on this point.
But I will say, for example, computing is labor.
Computing was labor. Computers, a lot
of jobs disappeared because computers
are automating a bunch of digital information
processing that you now don't need a human for.
So computers are labor, and that has played out.
Self-driving as an example is also computers doing
labor. That's already been playing
out. It's still business as usual.
You have a machine which is spitting out more
things like that at potentially faster pace.
Historically, we have examples
of the growth regime changing
where you went from 0.2% growth to 2% growth.
It seems very plausible to me that a machine which
is then spitting out the next self-driving
car and the next Internet and whatever…
I see where it's coming from.
At the same time, I do feel like
people make this assumption of, "We
have God in a box, and now it can do
everything," and it just won't look like that.
It's going to be able to do some of the things.
It's going to fail at some other things.
It's going to be gradually put into society,
and we'll end up with the same pattern. That
is my prediction. This assumption of suddenly
having a completely intelligent, fully flexible,
fully general human in a box, and we can dispense
it at arbitrary problems in society, I don't
think that we will have this discrete change.
I think we'll arrive at the same kind of
gradual diffusion of this across the industry.
It often ends up being misleading
in these conversations.
I don't like to use the word intelligence in
this context because intelligence implies you
think there'll be a single superintelligence
sitting in a server and it'll divine how
to come up with new technologies and
inventions that cause this explosion.
That's not what I'm imagining
when I'm imagining 20% growth.
I'm imagining that there are billions of
very smart human-like minds, potentially,
or that's all that's required.
But the fact that there's hundreds
of millions of them, billions of them, each
individually making new products, figuring
out how to integrate themselves into the economy.
If a highly experienced smart immigrant came to
the country, you wouldn't need to figure out how
we integrate them in the economy. They figure it
out. They could start a company, they could make
inventions, or increase productivity in the world.
We have examples, even in the current regime,
of places that have had 10-20% economic growth.
If you just have a lot of people and
less capital in comparison to the people,
you can have Hong Kong or Shenzhen or
whatever with decades of 10% plus growth.
There's a lot of really smart people who are
ready to make use of the resources and do
this period of catch-up because we've had this
discontinuity, and I think AI might be similar.
I understand, but I still think that
you're presupposing some discrete jump.
There's some unlock that we're waiting to claim.
And suddenly we're going to have
geniuses in data centers.
I still think you're presupposing
some discrete jump that has no historical
precedent that I can't find in any of the
statistics and that I think probably won't happen.
I mean, the Industrial Revolution is such a jump.
You went from 0.2% growth to 2% growth.
I'm just saying you'll see another jump like that.
I'm a little bit suspicious,
I would have to take a look.
For example, some of the logs are not very
good from before the Industrial Revolution.
I'm a bit suspicious of it but
I don't have strong opinions.
You're saying that this was a singular
event that was extremely magical.
You're saying that maybe there's going
to be another event that's going to
be just like that, extremely magical.
It will break the paradigm, and so on.
I actually don't think… The crucial thing with the
Industrial Revolution was that it was not magical.
If you just zoomed in, what you would see in 1770
or 1870 is not that there was some key invention.
But at the same time, you did move the
economy to a regime where the progress
was much faster and the exponential 10x'd.
I expect a similar thing from AI where it's
not like there's going to be a single moment
where we've made the crucial invention.
It’s an overhang that's being unlocked.
Like maybe there's a new energy source.
There's some unlock—in this case, some kind of
a cognitive capacity—and there's an overhang of
cognitive work to do.
That's right.
You're expecting that overhang to be filled by
this new technology when it crosses the threshold.
Maybe one way to think about it is
throughout history, a lot of growth
comes because people come up with ideas,
and then people are out there doing stuff to
execute those ideas and make valuable output.
Through most of this time, the population has
been exploding. That has been driving
growth. For the last 50 years, people
have argued that growth has stagnated.
The population in frontier countries
has also stagnated.
I think we go back to
the exponential growth in population that
causes hyper-exponential growth in output.
It's really hard to tell. I
understand that viewpoint. I
don't intuitively feel that viewpoint.
You recommended Nick Lane's book to me.
On that basis, I also found it super
interesting and I interviewed him.
I have some questions about thinking about
intelligence and evolutionary history.
Now that you, over the last 20 years of doing AI
research, you maybe have a more tangible sense of
what intelligence is, what it takes to develop it.
Are you more or less surprised as a result that
evolution just spontaneously stumbled upon it?
I love Nick Lane's books. I was just listening
to his podcast on the way up here.
With respect to intelligence and its
evolution, it's very, very recent.
I am surprised that it evolved.
I find it fascinating to think
about all the worlds out there.
Say there's a thousand planets
like Earth and what they look like.
I think Nick Lane was here talking
about some of the earliest parts.
He expects very similar life
forms, roughly speaking,
and bacteria-like things in most of them.
There are a few breaks in there.
The evolution of intelligence intuitively feels
to me like it should be a fairly rare event.
Maybe you should base it on
how long something has existed.
If bacteria were around for 2 billion years
and nothing happened, then going to eukaryote
is probably pretty hard because bacteria came
up quite early in Earth's evolution or history.
How long have we had animals?
Maybe a couple hundred million years,
multicellular animals that
run around, crawl, et cetera.
That’s maybe 10% of Earth's lifespan.
Maybe on that timescale it's not too tricky.
It's still surprising to me,
intuitively, that it developed.
I would maybe expect just a lot of animal-like
life forms doing animal-like things.
The fact that you can get something
that creates culture and knowledge
and accumulates it is surprising to me.
There's a couple of interesting follow-ups.
If you buy the Sutton perspective that the
crux of intelligence is animal intelligence…
The quote he said is "If you got to the
squirrel, you'd be most of the way to AGI."
We got to squirrel intelligence right after
the Cambrian explosion 600 million years ago.
It seems like what instigated that was the
oxygenation event 600 million years ago.
But immediately the intelligence algorithm
was there to make the squirrel intelligence.
It's suggestive that animal
intelligence was like that.
As soon as you had the oxygen in the
environment, you had the eukaryote,
you could just get the algorithm.
Maybe it was an accident that
evolution stumbled upon it so fast,
but I don't know if that suggests that
at the end it's going to be quite simple.
It's so hard to tell with any of this stuff.
You can base it a bit on how long
something has existed or how long
it feels like something has been bottlenecked.
Nick Lane is very good about describing this very
apparent bottleneck in bacteria and archaea.
For two billion years, nothing happened.
There’s extreme diversity of biochemistry,
and yet nothing grows to become animals.
Two billion years. I don't know that we've
seen exactly that kind of an equivalent with
animals and intelligence, to your point.
We could also look at it with respect
to how many times we think certain
intelligence has individually sprung up.
That's a really good thing to investigate.
One thought on that. There's hominid intelligence,
and then there's bird intelligence.
Ravens, etc., are extremely clever,
but their brain parts are quite distinct,
and we don't have that much in common.
That's a slight indication of maybe
intelligence springing up a few times.
In that case, you'd expect it more frequently.
A former guest, Gwern, and Carl Shulman, they’ve
made a really interesting point about that.
Their perspective is that the scalable algorithm
which humans have and primates have, arose in
birds as well, and maybe other times as well.
But humans found an evolutionary niche which
rewarded marginal increases in intelligence
and also had a scalable brain algorithm that
could achieve those increases in intelligence.
For example, if a bird had a bigger brain,
it would just collapse out of the air.
It's very smart for the size of
its brain, but it's not in a niche
which rewards the brain getting bigger.
It’s maybe similar to some really smart…
Like dolphins?
Exaclty, humans, we have hands that
reward being able to learn how to do tool use.
We can externalize digestion, more energy to
the brain, and that kicks off the flywheel.
Also stuff to work with. I'm guessing it would
be harder if I were a dolphin. How do you have
fire? The universe of things you can do in water,
inside water, is probably lower than
what you can do on land, just chemically.
I do agree with this viewpoint of these niches
and what's being incentivized. I still find it
miraculous. I would have expected things to
get stuck on animals with bigger muscles.
Going through intelligence is a
really fascinating breaking point.
The way Gwern put it is the reason it was so hard
is that it's a very tight line between being in
a situation where something is so important
to learn that it's not worth distilling the
exact right circuits directly back into your DNA,
versus it's not important enough to learn at all.
It has to be something that incentivizes
building the algorithm to learn in a lifetime.
You have to incentivize some kind of adaptability.
You want environments that are unpredictable
so evolution can't bake your
algorithms into your weights.
A lot of animals are pre-baked in this sense.
Humans have to figure it out at test
time when they get born.
You want these environments
that change really rapidly, where you
can't foresee what will work well.
You create intelligence to
figure it out at test time.
Quintin Pope had this interesting blog post
where he's saying the reason he doesn't
expect a sharp takeoff is that humans had the
sharp takeoff where 60,000 years ago we seem
to have had the cognitive architectures
that we have today. 10,000 years ago,
agricultural revolution, modernity.
What was happening in that 50,000 years?
You had to build this cultural scaffold where
you can accumulate knowledge over generations.
This is an ability that exists for
free in the way we do AI training.
In many cases they are literally distilled.
If you retrain a model, they can be trained
on each other, they can be trained
on the same pre-training corpus,
they don't literally have to start from scratch.
There's a sense in which it took humans a long
time to get this cultural loop going, but it just
comes for free with the way we do LLM training.
Yes and no. Because LLMs don't really
have the equivalent of culture.
Maybe we're giving them way too
much and incentivizing not to
create it or something like that.
But the invention of culture and of
written record and of passing down notes
between each other, I don't think there's
an equivalent of that with LLMs right now.
LLMs don't really have culture right now and
it's one of the impediments I would say.
Can you give me some sense of what
LLM culture might look like?
In the simplest case it would be a
giant scratchpad that the LLM can edit and as it's
reading stuff or as it's helping out with work,
it's editing the scratchpad for itself.
Why can't an LLM write a book for the other
LLMs? That would be cool. Why can't other
LLMs read this LLM's book and be inspired
by it or shocked by it or something like that?
There's no equivalence for any of this stuff.
Interesting. When would you expect
that kind of thing to start happening?
Also, multi-agent systems and a sort of
independent AI civilization and culture?
There are two powerful ideas in the
realm of multi-agent that have both
not been really claimed or so on.
The first one I would say is culture
and LLMs having a growing repertoire
of knowledge for their own purposes.
The second one looks a lot more
like the powerful idea of self-play.
In my mind it’s extremely powerful.
Evolution has a lot of competition
driving intelligence and evolution.
In AlphaGo more algorithmically,
AlphaGo is playing against itself and that's
how it learns to get really good at Go.
There's no equivalent of self-playing LLMs,
but I would expect that to also exist.
No one has done it yet.
Why can't an LLM for example, create a bunch
of problems that another LLM is learning to solve?
Then the LLM is always trying to serve more and
more difficult problems, stuff like that.
There's a bunch of ways to organize it.
It's a realm of research, but I haven't
seen anything that convincingly claims
both of those multi-agent improvements.
We're mostly in the realm of a single
individual agent, but that will change.
In the realm of culture also,
I would also bucket organizations.
We haven't seen anything like that convincingly
either. That's why we're still early.
Can you identify the key bottleneck
that's preventing this kind
of collaboration between LLMs?
Maybe the way I would put it is,
some of these analogies work and
they shouldn't, but somehow, remarkably, they do.
A lot of the smaller models, or the dumber models,
remarkably resemble a kindergarten student, or an
elementary school student or high school student.
Somehow, we still haven't graduated
enough where this stuff can take over.
My Claude Code or Codex, they still
feel like this elementary-grade student.
I know that they can take PhD quizzes,
but they still cognitively feel like a
kindergarten or an elementary school student.
I don't think they can create culture because
they're still kids. They're savant kids.
They have perfect memory of all this stuff.
They can convincingly create all
kinds of slop that looks really good.
But I still think they don't really know
what they're doing and they don't really
have the cognition across all these little
checkboxes that we still have to collect.
You've talked about how you were at Tesla
leading self-driving from 2017 to 2022.
And you firsthand saw this progress from cool
demos to now thousands of cars out there actually
autonomously doing drives.
Why did that take a decade?
What was happening through that time?
One thing I will almost instantly push
back on is that this is not even near done,
in a bunch of ways that I'm going to get to.
Self-driving is very interesting because
it's definitely where I get a lot of my
intuitions because I spent five years on it.
It has this entire history where the first demos
of self-driving go all the way to the 1980s.
You can see a demo from CMU in 1986.
There's a truck that's driving itself on
roads. Fast forward. When I was joining Tesla,
I had a very early demo of Waymo.
It basically gave me a perfect drive
in 2014 or something like that, so
a perfect Waymo drive a decade ago.
It took us around Palo Alto and so on
because I had a friend who worked there.
I thought it was very close and
then it still took a long time.
For some kinds of tasks and jobs and so on,
there's a very large demo-to-product gap where the
demo is very easy, but the product is very hard.
It's especially the case in cases like
self-driving where the cost
of failure is too high.
Many industries, tasks, and jobs maybe don't have
that property, but when you do have that property,
that definitely increases the timelines.
For example, in software engineering,
I do think that property does exist.
For a lot of vibe coding, it doesn't.
But if you're writing actual production-grade
code, that property should exist, because any
kind of mistake leads to a security
vulnerability or something like that.
Millions and hundreds of millions of
people's personal Social Security numbers
get leaked or something like that.
So in software, people should be careful,
kind of like in self-driving.
In self-driving, if things go wrong,
you might get injured. There are worse
outcomes. But in software, it's almost
unbounded how terrible something could be.
I do think that they share that property.
What takes the long amount of time and the way
to think about it is that it's a march of nines.
Every single nine is a constant amount of work.
Every single nine is the same amount of work.
When you get a demo and something works 90%
of the time, that's just the first nine.
Then you need the second nine, a third
nine, a fourth nine, a fifth nine.
While I was at Tesla for five years or so, we
went through maybe three nines or two nines.
I don't know what it is, but
multiple nines of iteration.
There are still more nines to go.
That's why these things take so long.
It's definitely formative for me, seeing
something that was a demo. I'm very
unimpressed by demos. Whenever I see demos of
anything, I'm extremely unimpressed by that.
If it's a demo that someone cooked
up as a showing, it's worse.
If you can interact with it, it's a bit better.
But even then, you're not done. You need the
actual product. It's going to face all these
challenges when it comes in contact
with reality and all these different
pockets of behavior that need patching.
We're going to see all this stuff play
out. It's a march of nines. Each nine is
constant. Demos are encouraging. It’s still
a huge amount of work to do.
It is a critical safety domain,
unless you're doing vibe coding,
which is all nice and fun and so on.
That's why this also enforced my
timelines from that perspective.
It's very interesting to hear you say that, that
the safety guarantees you need from software
are not dissimilar to self-driving.
What people will often say is that
self-driving took so long because
the cost of failure is so high.
A human makes a mistake on average every
400,000 miles or every seven years.
If you had to release a coding agent that
couldn't make a mistake for at least seven years,
it would be much harder to deploy.
But your point is that if you made a
catastrophic coding mistake, like breaking
some important system every seven years...
Very easy to do.
In fact, in terms of wall clock time,
it would be much less than seven years because
you're constantly outputting code like that.
In terms of tokens, it would be seven years.
But in terms of wall clock time...
In some ways, it's a much harder problem.
Self-driving is just one of
thousands of things that people do.
It's almost like a single vertical, I suppose.
Whereas when we're talking about
general software engineering,
it's even more... There's more surface area.
There's another objection people make to that
analogy, which is that with self-driving, what
took a big fraction of that time was solving
the problem of having basic perception
that's robust, building representations,
and having a model that has some common
sense so it can generalize to when it sees
something that's slightly out of distribution.
If somebody's waving down the road this way,
you don't need to train for it.
The thing will have some understanding
of how to respond to something like that.
These are things we're getting for free
with LLMs or VLMs today, so we don't have to
solve these very basic representation problems.
So now deploying AIs across different domains
will sort of be like deploying a self-driving
car with current models to a different city,
which is hard but not like a 10-year-long task.
I'm not 100% sure if I fully agree with that.
I don't know how much we're getting for free.
There's still a lot of gaps in
understanding what we are getting.
We're definitely getting more
generalizable intelligence in a
single entity, whereas self-driving is a
very special-purpose task that requires.
In some sense building a special-purpose task
is maybe even harder in a certain sense because
it doesn't fall out from a more general thing
that you're doing at scale, if that makes sense.
But the analogy still doesn't fully
resonate because the LLMs are still
pretty fallible and they have a lot of
gaps that still need to be filled in.
I don't think that we're
getting magical generalization
completely out of the box, in a certain sense.
The other aspect that I wanted to return to is
that self-driving cars are nowhere near done
still. The deployments are pretty minimal.
Even Waymo and so on has very few cars.
They're doing that roughly speaking
because they're not economical.
They've built something that lives in the future.
They've had to pull back the future,
but they had to make it uneconomical.
There are all these costs, not just
marginal costs for those cars and
their operation and maintenance, but
also the capex of the entire thing.
Making it economical is still
going to be a slog for them.
Also, when you look at these cars and
there's no one driving, I actually think
it's a little bit deceiving because there
are very elaborate teleoperation centers
of people kind of in a loop with these cars.
I don't have the full extent of it, but there's
more human-in-the-loop than you might expect.
There are people somewhere out there
beaming in from the sky.
I don't know if they're
fully in the loop with the driving.
Some of the time they are, but they're
certainly involved and there are people.
In some sense, we haven't actually removed
the person, we've moved them to
somewhere where you can't see them.
I still think there will be some work, as you
mentioned, going from environment to environment.
There are still challenges
to make self-driving real.
But I do agree that it's definitely crossed
a threshold where it kind of feels real,
unless it's really teleoperated.
For example, Waymo can't go to
all the different parts of the city.
My suspicion is that it's parts of the city
where you don't get good signal.
Anyway, I don't know anything
about the stack. I'm just making stuff up.
You led self-driving for five years at Tesla.
Sorry, I don't know anything
about the specifics of Waymo.
By the way, I love Waymo
and I take it all the time.
I just think that people are sometimes a
little bit too naive about some of the progress
and there's still a huge amount of work.
Tesla took in my mind a much more scalable
approach and the team is doing extremely well.
I'm kind of on the record for predicting
how this thing will go.
Waymo had an early start
because you can package up so many sensors.
But I do think Tesla is taking the more
scalable strategy and it's going
to look a lot more like that.
So this will still have to play out and hasn't.
But I don't want to talk about self-driving as
something that took a decade because it
didn't take it yet, if that makes sense.
Because one, the start is at 1980 and not 10
years ago, and then two, the end is not here yet.
The end is not near yet because when
we're talking about self-driving,
usually in my mind it's self-driving at scale.
People don't have to get a driver's license, etc.
I'm curious to bounce two other ways in
which the analogy might be different.
The reason I'm especially curious about this is
because the question of how fast AI is deployed,
how valuable it is when it's early
on is potentially the most important
question in the world right now.
If you're trying to model what the
year 2030 looks like, this is the question
you ought to have some understanding of.
Another thing you might think is one, you have
this latency requirement with self-driving.
I have no idea what the actual models are, but I
assume it’s like tens of millions of parameters
or something, which is not the necessary
constraint for knowledge work with LLMs.
Maybe it might be with computer use and stuff.
But the other big one is, maybe more
importantly, on this capex question.
Yes, there is additional cost to serving
up an additional copy of a model, but the opex
of a session is quite low and you can amortize
the cost of AI into the training run itself,
depending on how inference scaling goes and stuff.
But it's certainly not as much as building a whole
new car to serve another instance of a model.
So the economics of deploying more
widely are much more favorable.
I think that's right. If you're
sticking to the realm of bits,
bits are a million times easier than anything
that touches the physical world. I definitely
grant that. Bits are completely changeable,
arbitrarily reshuffleable at a very rapid speed.
You would expect a much faster adaptation also in
the industry and so on. What was the first one?
The latency requirements and
its implications for model size?
I think that's roughly right. I also
think that if we are talking about
knowledge work at scale, there will be some
latency requirements, practically speaking,
because we're going to have to create a
huge amount of compute and serve that.
The last aspect that I very briefly want
to also talk about is all the rest of it.
What does society think about it? What are
the legal ramifications? How is it working
legally? How is it working insurance-wise?
What are those layers of it and aspects of it?
What is the equivalent of people
putting a cone on a Waymo?
There are going to be equivalents of all that.
So I feel like self-driving is a very nice
analogy that you can borrow things from.
What is the equivalent of a cone in the car?
What is the equivalent of a teleoperating worker
who's hidden away and all the aspects of it.
Do you have any opinions on what this
implies about the current AI buildout,
which would 10x the amount of available compute
in the world in a year or two and maybe more
than 100x it by the end of the decade.
If the use of AI will be lower than
some people naively predict, does
that mean that we're overbuilding
compute or is that a separate question?
Kind of like what happened with railroads.
With what, sorry?
Was it railroads or?
Yeah, it was.
Yeah. There's historical precedent.
Or was it with the telecommunication industry?
Pre-paving the internet that only came a decade
later and creating a whole bubble in the
telecommunications industry in the late '90s.
I understand I'm sounding very pessimistic
here. I'm actually optimistic. I think this
will work. I think it's tractable. I'm
only sounding pessimistic because when
I go on my Twitter timeline, I see all
this stuff that makes no sense to me.
There's a lot of reasons for why that exists.
A lot of it is honestly just fundraising.
It's just incentive structures.
A lot of it may be fundraising.
A lot of it is just attention, converting
attention to money on the internet,
stuff like that.
There's a lot of
that going on, and I'm only reacting to that.
But I'm still overall very bullish on technology.
We're going to work through all this stuff.
There's been a rapid amount of progress.
I don't know that there's overbuilding.
I think we're going to be able to gobble up what,
in my understanding, is being built.
For example, Claude Code or OpenAI Codex
and stuff like that didn't even
exist a year ago. Is that right?
This is a miraculous technology that didn't exist.
There's going to be a huge amount of demand,
as we see the demand in ChatGPT already and so on.
So I don't know that there's overbuilding.
I'm just reacting to some of the very fast
timelines that people continue to say incorrectly.
I've heard many, many times over the course
of my 15 years in AI where very reputable
people keep getting this wrong all the time.
I want this to be properly calibrated, and some
of this also has geopolitical ramifications and
things like that with some of these questions.
I don't want people to make
mistakes in that sphere of things.
I do want us to be grounded in the
reality of what technology is and isn't.
Let's talk about education and Eureka.
One thing you could do is start another AI
lab and then try to solve those problems.
I’m curious what you're up to now,
and why not AI research itself?
I guess the way I would put it
is I feel some amount of determinism
around the things that AI labs are doing.
I feel like I could help out there, but I
don't know that I would uniquely improve it.
My personal big fear is that a lot of this
stuff happens on the side of humanity,
and that humanity gets disempowered by it.
I care not just about all the Dyson spheres
that we're going to build and that AI is
going to build in a fully autonomous way,
I care about what happens to humans.
I want humans to be well off in the future.
I feel like that's where I can a
lot more uniquely add value than
an incremental improvement in the frontier lab.
I'm most afraid of something depicted in movies
like WALL-E or Idiocracy or something like that,
where humanity is on the side of this stuff.
I want humans to be much,
much better in this future.
To me, this is through education
that you can achieve this.
So what are you working on there?
The easiest way I can describe it is
we're trying to build the Starfleet Academy.
I don’t know if you’ve watched Star Trek.
I haven’t.
Starfleet Academy is
this elite institution for frontier technology,
building spaceships, and graduating cadets to be
the pilots of these spaceships and whatnot.
So I just imagine an elite institution for
technical knowledge and a kind of school that's
very up-to-date and a premier institution.
A category of questions I have for you is
explaining how one teaches technical or
scientific content well, because you
are one of the world masters at it.
I'm curious both about how you think about
it for content you've already put out there
on YouTube, but also, to the extent it's any
different, how you think about it for Eureka.
With respect to Eureka, one thing that
is very fascinating to me about education
is that I do think education will pretty
fundamentally change with AIs on the side.
It has to be rewired and changed to some extent.
I still think that we're pretty early.
There's going to be a lot of people who
are going to try to do the obvious things.
Have an LLM and ask it questions.
Do all the basic things that you would
do via prompting right now.
It's helpful,
but it still feels to me a bit like slop.
I'd like to do it properly, and I think the
capability is not there for what I would want.
What I'd want is an actual tutor experience.
A prominent example in my mind is I was
recently learning Korean, so language learning.
I went through a phase where I was
learning Korean by myself on the internet.
I went through a phase where I was part of a small
class in Korea taking Korean with a bunch of other
people, which was really funny.
We had a teacher and 10
people or so taking Korean.
Then I switched to a one-on-one tutor.
I guess what was fascinating to me was, I think
I had a really good tutor, but just thinking
through what this tutor was doing for me and how
incredible that experience was and how high the
bar is for what I want to build eventually.
Instantly from a very short
conversation, she understood where I am
as a student, what I know and don't know.
She was able to probe exactly the kinds of
questions or things to understand my world model.
No LLM will do that for you
100% right now, not even close.
But a tutor will do that if they're good.
Once she understands, she really served
me all the things that I needed at
my current sliver of capability.
I need to be always appropriately challenged.
I can't be faced with something too hard or
too trivial, and a tutor is really good
at serving you just the right stuff.
I felt like I was the only constraint to learning.
I was always given the perfect information. I'm
the only constraint. I felt good because
I'm the only impediment that exists.
It's not that I can't find knowledge or
that it's not properly explained or etc.
It's just my ability to memorize and so on.
This is what I want for people.
How do you automate that?
Very good question. At
the current capability, you don't.
That's why I think it's not actually the
right time to build this kind of an AI tutor.
I still think it's a useful product,
and lots of people will build it, but the bar
is so high and the capability is not there.
Even today, I would say ChatGPT is an
extremely valuable educational product.
But for me, it was so fascinating
to see how high the bar is.
When I was with her, I almost felt
like there's no way I can build this.
But you are building it, right?
Anyone who's had a really good
tutor is like, "How are you going to build
this?" I'm waiting for that capability. I
did some AI consulting for computer vision.
A lot of times, the value that I brought to
the company was telling them not to use AI.
I was the AI expert, and they described the
problem, and I said, "Don't use AI."
This is my value add. I feel like it's
the same in education right now, where
I feel like for what I have in mind,
it's not yet the time, but the time will come.
For now, I'm building something that looks
maybe a bit more conventional that has a
physical and digital component and so on.
But it's obvious how this
should look in the future.
To the extent you're willing to
say, what is the thing you hope
will be released this year or next year?
I'm building the first course. I want to
have a really, really good course, the
obvious state-of-the-art destination
you go to to learn, AI in this case.
That's just what I'm familiar with, so it's
a really good first product to get to be really
good at it. So that's what I'm building. Nanochat,
which you briefly mentioned, is a capstone project
of LLM101N, which is a class that I'm building.
That's a really big piece of it.
But now I have to build out a lot of
the intermediates, and then I have to hire a small
team of TAs and so on and build the entire course.
One more thing that I would say is that many
times, when people think about education,
they think more about what I would say is
a softer component of diffusing knowledge.
I have something very hard and technical in mind.
In my mind, education is the very difficult
technical process of building ramps to knowledge.
In my mind, nanochat is a ramp to
knowledge because it's very simple.
It's the super simplified full-stack thing.
If you give this artifact to someone and they
look through it, they're learning a ton of stuff.
It's giving you a lot of what I call eurekas
per second, which is understanding per second.
That's what I want, lots of eurekas per second.
So to me, this is a technical problem of
how do we build these ramps to knowledge.
So I almost think of Eureka as maybe not that
different from some of the frontier labs
or some of the work that's going on there.
I want to figure out how to build these
ramps very efficiently so that people are
never stuck and everything is always
not too hard or not too trivial, and
you have just the right material to progress.
You're imagining in the short term that instead
of a tutor being able to probe your understanding,
if you have enough self-awareness to be able to
probe yourself, you're never going to be stuck.
You can find the right answer between talking
to the TA or talking to an LLM and
looking at the reference implementation.
It sounds like automation or
AI is not a significant part.
So far, the big alpha here is your
ability to explain AI codified
in the source material of the class.
That's fundamentally what the course is.
You always have to be calibrated to
what capability exists in the industry.
A lot of people are going to
pursue just asking ChatGPT, etc.
But I think right now, for example, if you go to
ChatGPT and you say, teach me AI, there's no way.
It's going to give you some slop.
AI is never going to write nanochat right now.
But nanochat is a really
useful intermediate point.
I'm collaborating with AI
to create all this material,
so AI is still fundamentally very helpful.
Earlier on, I built CS231n at Stanford,
which I think was the first deep learning
class at Stanford, which became very popular.
The difference in building out 231n
then and LLM101N now is quite stark.
I feel really empowered by the LLMs as they
exist right now, but I'm very much in the loop.
They're helping me build the
materials, I go much faster.
They're doing a lot of the boring stuff, etc.
I feel like I'm developing the course much faster,
and it's LLM-infused, but it's not yet at a
place where it can creatively create the content.
I'm still there to do that.
The trickiness is always
calibrating yourself to what exists.
When you imagine what is available
through Eureka in a couple of years, it
seems like the big bottleneck is going to be
finding Karpathys in field after field who can
convert their understanding into these ramps.
It would change over time. Right now,
it would be hiring faculty to help work
hand-in-hand with AI and a team of people
probably to build state-of-the-art courses.
Over time maybe some of the TAs can become AIs.
You just take all the course materials and then
I think you could serve a very good automated
TA for the student when they have more basic
questions or something like that.
But I think you'll need faculty
for the overall architecture of a
course and making sure that it fits.
So I see a progression of how this will evolve.
Maybe at some future point I'm not even that
useful and AI is doing most of the
design much better than I could.
But I still think that's going
to take some time to play out.
Are you imagining that people who have expertise
in other fields are then contributing courses,
or do you feel like it's quite
essential to the vision that you,
given your understanding of how you want to
teach, are the one designing the content?
Sal Khan is narrating all
the videos on Khan Academy.
Are you imagining something like that?
No, I will hire faculty because there
are domains in which I'm not an expert.
That's the only way to offer the state-of-the-art
experience for the student ultimately.
I do expect that I would hire faculty, but
I will probably stick around in AI for some time.
I do have something more conventional in mind for
the current capability than what
people would probably anticipate.
When I'm building Starfleet Academy, I do probably
imagine a physical institution, and maybe a tier
below that a digital offering that is not the
state-of-the-art experience you would get when
someone comes in physically full-time and we
work through material from start to end and
make sure you understand it. That's the physical
offering. The digital offering is a bunch of stuff
on the internet and maybe some LLM assistant.
It's a bit more gimmicky in a tier below, but
at least it's accessible to 8 billion people.
I think you're basically inventing college
from first principles for the tools that
are available today and just selecting
for people who have the motivation and the
interest of really engaging with material.
There's going to have to be a lot of not
just education but also re-education.
I would love to help out there because
the jobs will probably change quite a bit.
For example, today a lot of people are
trying to upskill in AI specifically.
I think it's a really good
course to teach in this respect.
Motivation-wise, before AGI motivation is very
simple to solve because people want to make money.
This is how you make money in the industry today.
Post-AGI is a lot more interesting possibly
because if everything is automated
and there's nothing to do for anyone,
why would anyone go to a school?
I often say that pre-AGI education
is useful. Post-AGI education is fun. In
a similar way, people go to the gym today.
We don't need their physical strength
to manipulate heavy objects because we
have machines that do that.
They still go to the gym.
Why do they go to the gym?
Because it's fun, it's healthy,
and you look hot when you have a six-pack.
It's attractive for people to do that
in a very deep, psychological,
evolutionary sense for humanity.
Education will play out in the same way.
You'll go to school like you go to the gym.
Right now, not that many people learn
because learning is hard. You bounce
from material. Some people overcome that
barrier, but for most people, it's hard.
It's a technical problem to solve.
It's a technical problem to do what my tutor
did for me when I was learning Korean.
It's tractable and buildable,
and someone should build it.
It's going to make learning
anything trivial and desirable, and people
will do it for fun because it's trivial.
If I had a tutor like that for any arbitrary piece
of knowledge, it's going to be so much easier to
learn anything, and people will do it.
They'll do it for the same
reasons they go to the gym.
That sounds different from using…
So post-AGI, you're using this as
entertainment or as self-betterment.
But it sounded like you had a vision
also that this education is relevant to
keeping humanity in control of AI. That sounds
different. Is it entertaining for some people,
but then empowerment for some others?
How do you think about that?
I do think eventually it's a bit of
a losing game, if that makes sense.
It is in the long term.
In the long term, which
is longer than maybe most people in the
industry think about, it's a losing game.
I do think people can go so far and we've barely
scratched the surface of how much a person can go.
That's just because people are bouncing off
of material that's too easy or too hard.
People will be able to go much further.
Anyone will speak five languages because
why not? Because it's so trivial. Anyone will know
all the basic curriculum of undergrad, et cetera.
Now that I'm understanding the
vision, that's very interesting.
It has a perfect analog in gym culture.
I don't think 100 years
ago anybody would be ripped.
Nobody would have been able to just spontaneously
bench two plates or three plates or something.
It's very common now because of this idea of
systematically training and lifting weights in
the gym, or systematically training to be able
to run a marathon, which is a capability
most humans would not spontaneously have.
You're imagining similar things for
learning across many different domains,
much more intensely, deeply, faster.
Exactly. I am betting a bit implicitly
on some of the timelessness of human nature.
It will be desirable to do all these things,
and I think people will look up
to it as they have for millennia.
This will continue to be true.
There's some evidence of that historically.
If you look at, for example, aristocrats, or you
look at ancient Greece or something like that,
whenever you had little pocket environments
that were post-AGI in a certain sense, people
have spent a lot of their time flourishing in a
certain way, either physically or cognitively.
I feel okay about the prospects of that.
If this is false and I'm wrong and we end up in a
WALL-E or Idiocracy future, then I don't even care
if there are Dyson spheres. This is a terrible
outcome. I really do care about humanity.
Everyone has to just be
superhuman in a certain sense.
It's still a world in which that is not enabling
us to… It's like the culture world, right?
You're not fundamentally going to be able
to transform the trajectory
of technology or influence
decisions by your own labor or cognition alone.
Maybe you can influence decisions because the AI
is asking for your approval, but it's not because
I've invented something or I've come up with a new
design that I'm really influencing the future.
Maybe. I think there will be a transitional
period where we are going to be
able to be in the loop and advance
things if we understand a lot of stuff.
In the long-term, that probably goes away.
It might even become a sport.
Right now you have powerlifters
who go extreme in this direction.
What is powerlifting in a cognitive era?
Maybe it's people who are really trying
to make Olympics out of knowing stuff.
If you have a perfect AI tutor,
maybe you can get extremely far.
I feel that the geniuses of
today are barely scratching the
surface of what a human mind can do, I think.
I love this vision. I also feel like the person
you have the most product-market fit with is me
because my job involves having to learn different
subjects every week, and I am very excited.
I'm similar, for that matter. A lot of people,
for example, hate school and want to get
out of it. I really liked school. I loved
learning things, et cetera.
I wanted to stay in school.
I stayed all the way until Ph.D. and
then they wouldn't let me stay longer,
so I went to the industry.
Roughly speaking, I love learning,
even for the sake of learning, but I also love
learning because it's a form of empowerment and
being useful and productive.
You also made a point that
was subtle and I want to spell it out.
With what’s happened so far with online
courses, why haven't they already enabled us to
enable every single human to know everything?
They're just so motivation-laden because there are
no obvious on-ramps and it's so easy to get stuck.
If you had this thing instead—like a really
good human tutor—it would just be such an
unlock from a motivation perspective.
I think so. It feels bad to bounce from
material. It feels bad. You get negative reward
from sinking an amount of time in something and it
doesn't pan out, or being completely bored because
what you're getting is too easy or too hard.
When you do it properly, learning feels good.
It's a technical problem to get there.
For a while, it's going to be AI plus human
collab, and at some point, maybe it's just AI.
Can I ask some questions about teaching well?
If you had to give advice to another educator
in another field that you're curious about to
make the kinds of YouTube tutorials you've made.
Maybe it might be especially interesting
to talk about domains where you can't
test someone's technical understanding by
having them code something up or something.
What advice would you give them?
That's a pretty broad topic. There are 10–20 tips
and tricks that I semi-consciously do probably.
But a lot of this comes
from my physics background.
I really, really did enjoy my physics background.
I have a whole rant on how everyone
should learn physics in early school
education because early school education is
not about accumulating knowledge or memory
for tasks later in the industry.
It's about booting up a brain.
Physics uniquely boots up the brain the
best because some of the things that they
get you to do in your brain during
physics is extremely valuable later.
The idea of building models and abstractions
and understanding that there's a first-order
approximation that describes most of the system,
but then there're second-order, third-order,
fourth-order terms that may or may not be present.
The idea that you're observing a very noisy
system, but there are these fundamental
frequencies that you can abstract away.
When a physicist walks into the class and
they say, "Assume there's a spherical cow,"
everyone laughs at that, but this is brilliant.
It's brilliant thinking that's very generalizable
across the industry because a cow can be
approximated as a sphere in a bunch of ways.
There's a really good book, for example, Scale.
It's from a physicist talking about biology.
Maybe this is also a book
I would recommend reading.
You can get a lot of really interesting
approximations and chart scaling laws of animals.
You can look at their heartbeats and
things like that, and they line up with
the size of the animal and things like that.
You can talk about an animal as a volume.
You can talk about the heat dissipation of that,
because your heat dissipation grows as the surface
area, which is growing as a square.
But your heat creation or generation
is growing as a cube.
So I just feel like physicists
have all the right cognitive tools to
approach problem solving in the world.
So because of that training, I
always try to find the first-order
terms or the second-order terms of everything.
When I'm observing a system or a thing, I have a
tangle of a web of ideas or knowledge in my mind.
I'm trying to find, what is the thing that
matters? What is the first-order component?
How can I simplify it? How can I have a
simplest thing that shows that thing, shows it in
action, and then I can tack on the other terms?
Maybe an example from one of my repos that I
think illustrates it well is called micrograd.
I don't know if you're familiar with this.
So micrograd is 100 lines of code
that shows backpropagation.
You can create neural networks
out of simple operations like plus and times, et
cetera. Lego blocks of neural networks. You build
up a computational graph and you do a forward
pass and a backward pass to get the gradients.
Now, this is at the heart of
all neural network learning.
So micrograd is a 100 lines of
pretty interpretable Python code,
and it can do forward and backward arbitrary
neural networks, but not efficiently.
So micrograd, these 100 lines of Python,
are everything you need to understand how
neural networks train. Everything else is just
efficiency. Everything else is efficiency. There's
a huge amount of work to get efficiency.
You need your tensors, you lay them out,
you stride them, you make sure
your kernels, orchestrating
memory movement correctly, et cetera.
It's all just efficiency, roughly speaking.
But the core intellectual piece of neural
network training is micrograd. It's 100 lines.
You can easily understand it. It's a recursive
application of chain rule to derive the gradient,
which allows you to optimize any
arbitrary differentiable function.
So I love finding these small-order terms and
serving them on a platter and discovering them.
I feel like education is the most intellectually
interesting thing because you have a tangle
of understanding and you're trying to lay
it out in a way that creates a ramp where
everything only depends on the thing before it.
I find that this untangling of knowledge is just
so intellectually interesting as a cognitive task.
I love doing it personally, but I just
have a fascination with trying to lay things
out in a certain way. Maybe that helps me.
It also makes the learning
experience so much more motivated.
Your tutorial on the transformer begins
with bigrams, literally a lookup table from,
"Here's the word right now, or here's
the previous word, here's the next word."
It's literally just a lookup table.
That’s the essence of it, yeah.
It’s such a brilliant way, starting with a
lookup table and then going to a transformer.
Each piece is motivated. Why would you add
that? Why would you add the next thing?
You could memorize the attention formula,
but having an understanding of why every
single piece is relevant, what problem it solves.
You're presenting the pain before you present a
solution, and how clever is that?
You want to take the student
through that progression.
There are a lot of other small
things that make it nice and engaging and
interesting. Always prompting the student.
There's a lot of small things like that are
important and a lot of good educators will do
this. How would you solve this? I'm not going to
present the solution before you guess. That would
be wasteful. That's a little bit of a…I don’t
want to swear but it’s a dick move towards you
to present you with the solution before I give
you a shot to try to come up with it yourself.
Because if you try to come up with it yourself,
you get a better understanding of what the action
space is, what the objective is, and then
why only this action fulfills that objective.
You have a chance to try it yourself, and you
have an appreciation when I give you the solution.
It maximizes the amount of
knowledge per new fact added.
Why do you think, by default, people who are
genuine experts in their field are often bad
at explaining it to somebody ramping up?
It's the curse of knowledge and expertise.
This is a real phenomenon, and I suffered
from it myself as much as I try not to.
But you take certain things for granted,
and you can't put yourself in the shoes
of new people who are just starting out.
This is pervasive and happens to me as
well. One thing that's extremely helpful.
As an example, someone was trying to show
me a paper in biology recently, and I just
instantly had so many terrible questions.
What I did was I used ChatGPT to ask the
questions with the paper in the context window.
It worked through some of the simple things.
Then I shared the thread to the person who
wrote that paper or worked on that work.
I felt like if they could see the dumb
questions I had, it might help
them explain better in the future.
For my material, I would love it if people
shared their dumb conversations with ChatGPT
about the stuff that I've created
because it really helps me put myself
again in the shoes of someone who's starting out.
Another trick that just works astoundingly well.
If somebody writes a paper or a blog post or an
announcement, it is in 100% of cases that just
the narration or the transcription of how they
would explain it to you over lunch is way more,
not only understandable, but actually
also more accurate and scientific,
in the sense that people have a bias
to explain things in the most abstract,
jargon-filled way possible and to clear
their throat for four paragraphs before
they explain the central idea.
But there's something about
communicating one-on-one with a person
which compels you to just say the thing.
Just say the thing. I saw that
tweet, I thought it was really good.
I shared it with a bunch of people.
I noticed this many, many times.
The most prominent example is that I
remember back in my PhD days doing research.
You read someone's paper, and you
work to understand what it's doing.
Then you catch them, you're having beers
at the conference later, and you ask them,
"So this paper, what were you doing? What is the
paper about?" They will just tell you these three
sentences that perfectly captured the essence
of that paper and totally give you the idea.
And you didn't have to read the paper.
It's only when you're sitting at the table
with a beer or something, and they're
like, "Oh yeah, the paper is just,
you take this idea, you take that idea and try
this experiment and you try out this thing."
They have a way of just putting it
conversationally just perfectly.
Why isn't that the abstract?
Exactly. This is coming from the
perspective of how somebody who's trying to
explain an idea should formulate it better.
What is your advice as a student to other
students, if you don't have a Karpathy
who is doing the exposition of an idea?
If you're reading a paper from somebody
or reading a book, what strategies do
you employ to learn material you're
interested in in fields you're not an expert at?
I don't know that I have unique tips and tricks,
to be honest. It's a painful process. One thing
that has always helped me quite a bit is—I
had a small tweet about this—learning things
on demand is pretty nice. Learning depth-wise.
I do feel you need a bit of alternation of
learning depth-wise, on demand—you're trying
to achieve a certain project that you're going
to get a reward from—and learning breadth-wise,
which is just, "Oh, let's do whatever 101,
and here's all the things you might need."
Which is a lot of school—does breadth-wise
learning, like, "Oh, trust me, you'll need
this later," that kind of stuff. Okay, I trust
you. I'll learn it because I guess I need it.
But I love the kind of learning
where you'll get a reward out of
doing something, and you're learning on demand.
The other thing that I've found extremely helpful.
This is an aspect where education is a bit more
selfless, but explaining things to people is a
beautiful way to learn something more deeply.
This happens to me all the time.
It probably happens to other people too because
I realize if I don't really understand something,
I can't explain it.
I'm trying and I'm like,
"Oh, I don't understand this."
It's so annoying to come to terms with that.
You can go back and make sure you understood it.
It fills these gaps of your understanding.
It forces you to come to terms
with them and to reconcile them.
I love to re-explain things and people
should be doing that more as well.
That forces you to manipulate the knowledge
and make sure that you know what you're
talking about when you're explaining it.
That's an excellent note to close on. Andrej,
that was great.
Thank you.